Hey everybody,
what's up?
How was your weekend?
Don't answer that.
We're not really talking.
That's just the awkward thing though.
The get the get the podcast started words,
they don't really mean anything.
It takes a few words from here on out.
Everything means something.
Allegedly.
This episode of the Joe Rogan experience is brought to you by Squarespace.
Congratulations to all those folks who won the Squarespace contest.
He should be getting all your goods,
your higher prime meat tee shirt and your swag bag from Squarespace and you get
a free year of Squarespace service.
There was some really cool,
um,
entrance,
a lot of them really too many to,
to pick four,
but we managed to pick four that we're,
uh,
we're pretty striking.
So,
uh,
the what,
what Squarespace is for people to,
in going,
what the fuck's he talking about?
Squarespace is a fantastic website for creating websites.
It's really intuitive,
super easy to use.
It's one that I've had virtually zero complaints about,
not virtually actually when I say virtually because I was trying to sound smart.
It seems like a good word to fit in there.
Um,
it's used by,
you know,
somebody,
different companies that would have ordinarily had to pay someone a,
a tremendous amount of money to create something just as cool and slick the way
they have it is set up so that if you can do normal computer things like go
online,
dragon drop,
you know,
click on things.
It's,
if you could do like normal things in the Internet,
create a word document,
you could figure out how to make your own beautiful website with things like
having an online store,
very easy to set up for musicians,
musicians can sell digital music from Squarespace.
It's just a really cool company that it just a product that's excellent and
works really well.
And for a free trial and 10% off your first purchase,
go to squarespace.com and enter in the code Joe and the number one that's Joe
and the number one for this month of January that we're in right now.
Squarespace has also launched a new help website that will deliver better
customer service.
They actually have an ad running during the Superbowl.
Damn Squarespace is stepping up.
Um,
it's beautiful designs for you to start with and a lot of style options you need
create a unique website.
The ones that were entered into the contest were,
were really excellent.
Just a perfect examples of what can be done because it really,
you still look,
you know,
like most people's websites,
you either had someone make it a new what they're doing or your website looks
like shit,
but now you can make your own and it looks awesome.
squarespace.com use the offer code Joe and the number one,
that's all one word,
Joe and the number one for a free trial and 10% off your first purchase.
Their ad has a new creepy baby guy.
Creepy baby holding a guy.
That's a baby.
Wow.
Why are you trying to freak me out man?
I know your bet.
They're trying to freak me out.
That is weird.
These babies in weird ways and w commercials,
it's very unusual the just for men baby and is this a bunch of like weird
commercials with babies?
Get to talk babies,
do things that normal people do.
We're fucking weird man.
Humans are weird.
Anyway,
we're also brought to you by legal zoom.
Um,
much like Squarespace,
which a lot of our friends have used legal zoom.
It's been used by a lot of our friends on it was formed through legal zoom.
Brian formed his death squad company through legal zoom.
You can't get a better,
simpler,
easier way to to do law type shit that you would ordinarily have to go to a
lawyers office for.
You would not ordinarily,
you'd have to make an appointment,
he'd have to go there.
You'd have to wait in line.
You'd have to,
I don't know if you wait in line,
you have to wait to wait.
I don't think there's a line.
I'm exaggerating.
The point is it costs a lot of fucking money to go to the lawyer,
but you can start a business incorporate or start an lll LLC.
Well,
I don't know what an ELA is,
but you can start an LLC,
which is like limited legal something or another.
What does that stand for?
Limited liability company.
Yeah,
and you could do that for just 99 bucks.
You can also do a last will for just 69 bucks,
get a living trust,
power of attorney,
more,
all that kind of stuff.
And legal zoom also has a connection to a series of independent attorney.
So if you panic and you're like,
this is the fuck I can't do this,
legal zoom will connect you to independent attorneys who can help you through
the process,
help you through your process.
Um,
if you're in the middle of it and you're like,
this can't be legal,
I'm going to jail.
I'm scared.
I need to talk to a real lawyer.
Don't panic legals and we'll hook you up.
Legal Zoom is not a law firm,
but they can connect to you with a third party attorney and provide you with
self help services.
And now you get a special discount from listening to this podcast.
Make sure you enter Rogan in the referral box at checkout for more savings.
Um,
this is probably the easiest way,
ladies and gentlemen,
that you can be naked and do law.
You can do legal things completely naked from the freedom.
Yeah,
but you've got to put a piece of tape over your,
you're a little webcam because the fucking government,
man,
they're sneaking in there looking at you.
Do you have a piece of tape over their address?
Even better.
I have an eff sticker.
Eff The electronic frontier foundation that fights for civil liberties on the
Internet and they have their own brand.
It's thinkers you can buy,
so they have their own stickers that cover webcams.
Yes,
and they don't,
they don't leave.
They don't leave glue residue.
So you can peel it off and put it back on if you want to talk someone into do
video.
Right.
It's beautiful.
Yeah.
It's a great little thing.
The Internet,
you can't fuck with the Internet.
It's too strong.
It got out of control.
You fucked up government,
I think.
Just keep it on the government.
You fucked up.
You messed up.
He just,
an Internet was your downfall.
When they go look in the history of the human beings and they go back to
different errors,
they will look at the,
the history of the Internet called bullae.
They didn't see that coming.
Oh my goodness.
Anyway on the Internet,
go to legal zoom.com how about that?
Get yourself an LLC.
The is right.
Uh,
patents and things.
Well,
that's the most important thing that I'll see on legal.
Zoom did gym.
The thing is a lot of this law stuff is not that complicated,
but they make you pay,
you know,
150 bucks to do it with an attorney and they really just fill in a form for you.
Most people can do it themselves,
so it's,
yeah,
it works.
It's great.
It's a trap.
It's a trap,
but for now,
legal zooms legal.
Who knows what's going to happen.
Go there.
Legal zoom.com and a used the row,
the word Rogan in the referral box at checkout for more savings.
We're also brought to you by on@dotcomonig.com the human optimization website.
What is essentially is all things that I use,
whether it's a physical fitness equipment,
strength and conditioning equipment like kettle bells or battle ropes or ab
wheels or anything that we find that is that can aid human performance,
whether it's human physical performance,
whether it's cognitive performance,
whether it aids and enhancing your mood.
We actually have a supplement called new mood that's a five HTP and l tryptofan
supplement that actually enhances your body's ability to produce dopamine.
It makes you feel better.
So much so that there's people that are on antidepressants or their doctors tell
them to not take five HTP cause you don't want to get too much of that.
Good loving too much of that.
Yeah.
What's that?
Ecstasy like?
Why?
Why wouldn't you want to go to,
I guess serotonin
overload or something like that?
You can,
you kind of real issues.
You're not,
you know,
it's like too much of a bat,
a good thing.
It's still bad.
That's why if guys do steroids and they get to be 350 pounds there,
Dick just shuts down your Dick's done too much of a good thing.
You know,
your liver is freaking out.
It's got to process all the shit that you're pumping into it.
It's all about balance,
balance and uh,
all the things that on it.
Um,
whether it's uh,
the strength and conditioning equipment or the supplements I'll share that I
use.
And if we find something out there,
we tried to sell it.
We tried to sell you the best coconut oil.
We tried to sell you the best buffalo bars,
best hemp seed oil from the finest hemp seed with the highest levels of protein
in it.
We just tried to sell you the very best shit available and we sell some
controversial things,
uh,
things like nootropics.
And we,
uh,
we funded a double blind placebo study that we'll be able to talk more about in
February,
but we were spending a lot of money to back up the existing science on
nootropics because I know a lot of people fear that things are snake oil.
And I,
I,
that's a good fear.
It's good.
And it's good because it forces companies who sell legitimate things to do the
proper testing and just show you,
there's plenty of examples of things on late night TV.
They're telling you that your Dick's going to grow or you know this.
I mean that's just one example of things that you know are dubious and you know
they're making money because if they weren't making money they wouldn't be
having these commercials.
There is nothing that makes your Dick Rowe.
If they did on it would have it on the God damn front page.
We'd have Dick Rowe pills,
weed,
fucking sell them,
buy crates.
The shit doesn't work.
Nothing makes your Dick Rowe.
Okay.
Did the moment they figure it out.
Go to on.com O.
N.
I.
T.
We'll fucking have it.
If there's something out there,
we'll have it,
but until now we're just trying to sell you this stuff that does work.
Because of the controversy.
We have a very loose money back guarantee on,
on their supplements,
on things like new mood or Alpha brain.
There is a 90 pill,
30 day,
100% money back guarantee.
Excuse me,
30 pill
coffin here,
I reversed it.
It's a 30 pill,
90 day.
So the first 30 pills,
you have a 90 day 100% money back guarantee and you don't even have to return
the product.
You don't have to send it back in.
You just,
you use what you just said.
This stuff's socks.
You get your money back.
The what we're trying to do is sell you something that is so good that you don't
have that temptation.
And if you honestly do try Alpha brain and you say it didn't do anything for
you,
I want you to have your money back.
I think that's good.
Don't buy it.
And again,
don't,
don't buy it anymore.
And you know,
maybe it's just not for you,
but that's,
I don't,
I don't want anybody to feel ripped off.
We're so confident that what we're selling is effective and works for us.
That we're willing to have such a,
uh,
a loose and limber moneyback guarantee,
but we're just going to continue to try to sell you the best shit that we can
find.
And,
uh,
whatever science that we can do on one of her supplements,
we will absolutely do that as well.
You use a codeword Rogan and you will save 10% off any and all supplements.
All Right Ladies and gentlemen,
thanks to everybody who came out to Chicago.
We had a great fucking time this past weekend.
It was cold as shit,
but the people are cool as fuck.
Um,
Andreas Antonopoulos is here.
We're going to talk about cryptocurrency and we're going to let some bitches,
no,
the Joe Rogan experience.
Hey Joe Rogan podcast all day.
So I love the fact that you can get on the Internet and you have a conversation
on Twitter with anybody and the word bitcoin comes up.
And then this swarm of people from like all these different directions.
Andreas Antonopoulos,
judge,
Bitcoin,
Jesus,
g,G ,
G,
g.
So you know,
eye contact,
you,
you contact me.
Boom.
A week later we're sitting in front of each other and want to talk about bitcoin
in a million.
People are going to hear about it.
I mean,
does the Internet is fucking beautiful.
It's magic.
I mean it's just,
it is what it should have.
The would communication with human beings should have been a long time ago.
I think it would have all the things that took off and gained ground and gain
momentum throughout human history,
whether it's religion or whether it's colt rituals,
ritualistic behavior like the,
all that shit wouldn't have happened if the Internet was around.
The Internet would have went under Dah,
Dah,
Dah.
It's not that.
It's this,
why does it,
does it stop?
What are you saying?
Look right here.
Here's,
here's the studies.
There's so much misconception and so disinformation that human beings have been
fed throughout history.
I think we're just now starting to grasp how huge it is that this is the first
time in history where information just flows just back and forth and the most
valuable stuff is free.
The most valuable information that you can get online,
absolutely free,
which is,
you know what's the best thing about the internet is that it's a dumb network.
It transmits information from point a to point B and it doesn't care what that
information is.
So if you come up with a new idea,
a new application,
and you stick it on the edge of the network,
you can transmit that information to anybody else.
And there's a cellist principle behind it,
net neutrality that you don't prioritize your content instead of somebody
else's,
you allow equal access to all for all contents.
And the Internet doesn't care.
It's just Ip.
All that seizes bites and it just moves them.
And then one day somebody invented a new application and stuck it on the edge,
the Internet of money.
And that's what I'm here to talk about today because they didn't need to ask
anybody permission.
And they launched bitcoin and it happened.
And now that it's here,
it's enabling other people to launch money applications on the Internet and it's
going to fuel the Internet even faster than we've seen before.
Yeah,
this is a very strange time,
uh,
in,
in that there's actually people that are just starting to accept bitcoin.
One of the first crypto currencies for,
for solid objects like tiger direct is starting to accept bitcoin.
For computers.
You can order a computer on tiger direct from fucking bitcoins.
And I'll send you a God damn actual computer that you can get online with that
starts becoming real
well tiger direct can very simply take that bit coin and immediately converted
into dollars so they don't even have any exchange risk and other people are
willing to give them dollars for it because they see it as valuable.
And that's all money is.
It's a shared understanding that this thing has value because it's scarce that
it's not around a lot.
It's hard to make.
You can't copy it,
you can't fake it.
And once you have those three things,
you have money.
Okay,
then it has value.
Plain those.
How is it possible?
Well,
what exactly is bitcoin for people that are completely on the outside on this
and they listen to this podcast and I'm like,
what the fuck is he talking about?
New Money,
bitcoin.
What is,
what is a bitcoin?
So there's layers to this.
I'll start at the top layer at the top.
Player.
Bitcoin is cash on the intranet and I say cash because it's not just any kind of
money.
It's not like an account or credit card.
It's not like paypal.
This is cash,
which means that when you have it,
you have it sitting on your computer as digital cash.
And then when you send it,
it goes directly from your computer to the recipients wallet as digital cash.
Now that's the top layer underneath.
This is basically a shared ledger.
That means that everyone can see all of the transactions and the whole network
agrees that Andrea sent Joe,
you know,
a 10th of a bitcoin.
Great.
Now the whole network knows it.
So that means Joel has a 10th of a bitcoin and simply based on that,
you can move money around.
Um,
there's a lot of security in some complex math,
but basically bitcoin is a standard.
It's an agreement on how to exchange money on the Internet,
just like the web is a standard on how to create pages and view them in a
browser.
There's a lot of skepticism when it comes to bitcoin.
Um,
uh,
I've spoken to people that are financial wizards that are skeptical and I've
spoken to people that are just,
you know,
the that have just looked into cryptocurrencies because of the rise of the
popularity of bitcoin.
They said,
this doesn't make sense.
There's no room for inflation.
There's not enough people,
not enough bitcoins does it?
It's not going to work.
How are they going to create more?
There's all these different arguments about why do you think that what we're
seeing with the rise of bitcoin is instead of just addressing all these
financial concerns and all these people that are used to the current market and
the place that it's at right now,
the the the,
the standards that the way they run things instead of that bitcoin just creates
a completely new network driven community driven money and says fuck all your
old rule.
It's social network of funny.
It's peer to peer money.
It means to wrecked from one individual to another individual no matter where
they are on the world in seconds for almost free and that has never happened
before.
Do you think that part of the skepticism though is because of the fact this
other system exists?
Sure.
And that this other system is our norm,
our standard.
And we don't want to look at like something like bitcoin objectively just say,
okay,
let's pretend that our current system of stocks and bonds,
but it's not just,
yeah,
and it's not just the system.
It's so much part of our culture.
Money is one of the first technologies,
you know,
fire wheel money.
Money has existed for tens of thousands of years,
going back to shells and feathers and knots on string and giant rocks in the
Polynesian islands and then through the Iron Age to minted coins stamped with
emperors faces.
This stuff has been part of our culture for tens of thousands of years.
And as a result,
it's no longer just technology.
It's a cultural phenomenon and you are steeped in it from the moment you're
born.
And so you acquire certain notions of what money is and how it works.
And you think that the current system by which money works is the only system
because we've had it for thousands of years.
And even in computer science,
the idea of getting distributed computers to agree on something without
cheating,
we thought that problem couldn't be solved until 2008 when the invention behind
bitcoin solve that problem and created a new way of doing money.
And it's going to take a lot of time to understand it.
Primarily because people don't really understand money as it is today.
They don't understand how banks work.
They understand how the Federal Reserve creates money.
They don't understand a debt based system for money.
I've read about it.
I don't understand it.
Well,
I read,
I read many things.
I've watched documentaries understand it.
Most of the people when they first face bitcoin,
they start asking questions about money and it quickly becomes apparent to all
of us when we do this,
that we don't know much about money.
So then we learned about money and we start reading about money.
But um,
you know,
it's,
it's very much part of the culture to the point where I'll talk to people about
bitcoin and they'll say,
well,
it's not backed by gold.
So how can it have value?
The dollar hasn't been backed by gold for like 60 years in,
and you talk to the average person in the streets and they still think there's
some gold in a vault and that stuff does it.
It doesn't exist.
I'm happen to all the gold in the vault watches.
Well,
that's a whole other question.
I mean,
the real issue is this heath,
we haven't been on a gold standard for decades and all of the currencies in the
world are created based on the productive capacity of the country and the legal
system,
and because they have value,
because you pay your taxes with them and then they just float freely in exchange
rates.
So they very against each other in the,
because the dollar is used to buy oil,
it's the world reserve currency and all the other currencies are measured
against that,
but there is no gold and that's fine.
That doesn't mean it doesn't have value.
It absolutely has.
That fucks up a lot of old action movies,
man.
Yeah,
it really does.
Those movies where you would break into the vault.
Yeah,
Lone Ranger.
The bars of gold there would always be brick shaped.
Well the thing is gold isn't that efficient for building a currency on because
the rates of which you can produce gold,
um,
is his face.
Then it's hoarded and you know,
you have certain problems.
Now the Nice thing about bitcoin is that it takes,
um,
it takes the same concept of scarcity a,
of having something that is a limited resource,
but it does it by algorithm.
So you essentially have math that says that every 10 minutes,
25 new bitcoin is created by the network as a whole with all of the computing
capacity of the network.
And that's fixed.
And every four years we create half as much every 10 minutes.
So in four years it goes down to 12 and a half bitcoin every 10 minutes.
And then it goes down to six and a quarter and it keeps going down until you
meant the last bit coin.
And then you're done 21 million coins.
It's done.
And the idea is that you provide a sound basis for money.
Something that is rare,
cannot be forged,
is easily transportable.
And that is the form of currency.
So 21 million bitcoins and then it's over.
They will,
well,
there's our,
you can divide a Bitcoin,
100 million pieces,
so it goes down to eight digits.
And that means the lowest units is called a Satoshi.
And there's 100 million satoshis in a bitcoin.
So 21 million times 100 million,
21 quadrillion coins,
plenty coins.
Jesus Christ.
Why am,
why is that so complicated?
Why is it like 100 million?
Um,
well I think part of the reason is that it's easier to write a number without a
decimal points and just to write a smaller units with lots of Zeros after it.
Um,
it's easier in computer terms,
the handle numbers that way,
but,
but most importantly,
it doesn't matter because what you see on your screen at today might be a bit
coin.
Actually,
on my wallets,
I use Millie bet coins,
thousands of a bitcoin because of corresponds more to my daily purchases.
You know,
maybe a few years from now you're going to be using a millions of a bitcoin to
look at your balance.
It doesn't matter what you call a unit.
Uh,
the point is what value does it have because someone else is willing to give you
that amount of money.
Well,
but we have like sort of this established ideal in our hand,
what a dollar is worth.
This is a $100 that looks like a thousand dollar computer.
Sure.
You know,
we have this idea in our head and that idea will be completely out the window.
And you started talking about millions of bitcoins and trying to like figure out
like how much is a laptop from tiger dot.
If I buy a laptop,
is that 200 millions of a bitcoin?
Well,
no,
we just talk in millibits and millibit is almost about a dollars.
It's about 800 something today.
Um,
so,
uh,
middle of bed.
So a computer with cost you about 1200 millivolts,
1200 megabits.
All right,
that seems normal as long as we can get it down to numbers that like correspond
with dollars.
But here's the thing,
do you know what I mean?
This is a global
bull phenomenon and there are so many countries out there whether currency,
very 30% a year and some now for 30% a month.
And in those countries there is no stable anything and even the dollar,
we look at it today and we have this idea of what its value is,
but if you look back historically it's value has been declining for almost a
century now and today's dollar is worth the same as you know,
13 cents at the beginning of the previous century.
We don't see that on a day to day base because it's one of the most stable
currencies,
but there's 193 currencies out there and 180 of them are far,
far worse than the dollar in terms of management.
And a couple of handful of them absolutely horrible.
And the people trapped in these countries can now use bitcoin.
So this is a lot broader than just the U s dollar.
It's not just a matter of is this going to be comfy for consumers?
This can bring people from countries that have extreme poverty,
extreme problems,
that are not necessarily based on a lack of technology,
that have phones,
that can use bitcoin for example.
But because of politics that trapped in this situation recently,
I was in Argentina in Buenos Iris and now they're having an even worst currency
crisis.
Uh,
they devalued 18% last week,
uh,
locked that lockdown.
They can't take money out of the country.
They can't buy things online.
If they buy something online,
they have to go pick it up from a customs office and pay 50% tax on it.
The,
the countries trying to lock in the money,
right?
And you have these extreme situations and then you have a choice suddenly.
So bitcoin is a lot bigger than just,
you know,
a consumer thing for here in the u s
how would someone get bitcoins from those environments?
Like,
so let's say you're in some poor third world country with a really incredibly
corrupt system and fucked up economy.
How someone from
that,
that environment get a bitcoin?
Well.
So,
um,
even in Argentina for example,
which is not,
uh,
you know,
this a second world country that was once the,
the Paris of Latin America and it's still a beautiful place.
Um,
but it has these difficult political problems.
It's illegal to trade on the black market dollars for pesos,
right?
So you can't go in and if you're a tourist and say,
okay,
I'm just going to give some dude on the street to hundred,
that's illegal.
And yet on every street corner,
the someone who will sell you pesos.
And last time I went to,
I just asked them,
will you take bitcoin?
And guess what?
Some of them said,
never heard of it.
And some of them said,
yeah,
we're trying to do that now.
Can you help us?
Whoa.
So suddenly you have Jordi have this black market or gray market for currencies.
And,
and in the u s you never see this,
but if you travel abroad,
you see this all the time.
Most places in the world,
the official currency rate versus the one you can get from a corner.
Uh,
you know,
a street sale seller who is,
selling vegetables and the local currency for dollars.
You know,
you can do that to ever in so many countries in the world.
And for them it's a normal thing.
Now,
this,
this novel idea of this new currency,
is this something that anyone right now is Lik living off of?
Is anybody getting paid by bitcoin and paying their rent by bitcoin buying their
food with bitcoin?
So first of all,
my income is entirely,
bitcoin has been for several months now.
How many months?
Um,
since October perhaps.
And before that I just didn't have as much income because I've been working on
Bitcoin,
you know,
to,
to a level almost obsession because it's such a fascinating technology for me.
And as someone who works in security and distributed systems,
this is,
you know,
a once in a lifetime opportunity to be involved in something monumental.
Just like when I was involved in the early days of the Internet as,
as a,
as a young scientist and now I can do it again with bitcoin.
So I've been obsessed,
but since October I've also been making a living off bitcoin and I get paid in
bitcoin.
Wow.
And how do you pay your rent?
I convert some of it to dollars to pay my landlord until I can persuade them to
take bitcoin directly.
But it won't take that long because every time I pay in dollars I say,
would you rather take bitcoin?
And that's one of the easiest ways to get bitcoin by the ways.
So find someone who wants to pay for something with bitcoin.
Wow.
And so they're not ready to yet,
but you think that perhaps they're thinking about it.
I might be able to pay your rent in bitcoin.
I'm
always surprised by WHO's going to take my bitcoin.
Sometimes it's a taxi driver in Germany.
Sometimes you know it's a,
it's a give it to them that they install an app on their phone.
I'm going to give you some before the end of the show for sure.
They installed an APP on their phone and I just zap it across just like I could
zap it from hair to Kuala Lumpur in two seconds.
I can stop it across the table.
Whoa.
It's just like sending an email and,
and in fact it's,
it's remarkably similar.
I just get,
you'll install an app and then you'll give me your bitcoin address,
which is like your email kinda.
And then I'll zap some bitcoin across the u and few seconds later you'll see it
pop up on your phone.
And that is real bitcoin.
It's,
and it's on your phone.
It's not sitting in a bank somewhere.
You don't have the promise that maybe when you try to withdraw it,
you're going to have it.
This isn't,
you know,
a credit or something like that.
This is the actual digital amount is locked by a key that's on your phone and is
recognized by the entire network is a valid transaction.
If you left your phone behind in a drunken stupor,
someone got ahold of your phone,
could they wreck you financially?
Yeah.
Dammit.
Say No.
So No,
I'm going to be,
I'm going to be 100% honest.
There are,
there are ways to protect yourself.
So,
for example,
on mine,
phone wallet,
first of all it has my phone has a pin.
Then my wallet has a pin of its own.
And then there's one thing that I can't do with a wallet right away,
which is I can't send money.
I can look at my balance,
I can receive money,
all of that just with a pin.
But if I want to send money and have to enter another password or pin personal
identification numbers.
Yeah.
So I've got a couple of different passwords so that my wallet isn't just sitting
there.
But again,
as I said,
this is digital cash.
So if you had a wallet stuffed with cash and you left isn't a cafe,
what happens to it?
Somebody steals it or you get really lucky.
And so when he gives it back to you.
Yeah,
exactly.
I'm some of that money.
Exactly.
But most likely,
you know,
you don't have someone to call and say,
Hey,
get that cash back for me.
It was stolen from so-and-so location.
It's gone back up.
Yes,
you lose your phone.
Can you back up from,
from a cloud.
Well,
that's the nice thing about it because unlike physical money,
this is digital money.
You can make copies of it.
You can't spend both copies,
you can only spend one,
but you can make copies so you can make backups.
You can even back up right onto a piece of paper,
which is what I do in this called a paper wallet.
So I have printed pieces of paper with Bitcoin keys on them and I make two
copies and I put one in a safe and I put the other in a safety deposit box and I
send bitcoin to those wallets.
And then I basically have my bitcoin sitting on paper in a bank.
What kind of like a bearer bond?
It's like a bearer bonds,
you know,
or like a stock certificate.
But the only differences that that magic number that's on there allows me to
redeem that bitcoin anywhere in the world.
This is way more sophisticated than I thought it was.
I thought it was a bunch of dorks running round,
fake fucking duns and dragons money.
Oh No,
this is,
this is way more sophisticated.
We'll get to talking about how you can use this to do stocks,
bonds,
distributed companies,
autonomous companies.
Now when you pay your kinds of things,
when you pay your rent and you take your bitcoin,
you convert it to money,
who's giving you money for Bitcoin?
People want to buy bitcoin.
So how do you find these people on craigslist?
So there's a number of ways.
The,
the,
the uh,
the straightforward one,
if you come from the old banking style world is you open a brokerage account on
a virtual currency exchange that will exchange dollars,
yen,
euros,
whatever to bitcoin or even some other cryptocurrencies.
And then you can go there and you can wire transfer,
um,
you know,
using your bank account,
you can wire transfer money into the brokerage account as you would to buy IBM
stock.
You wire him some money to your brokerage and then you buy some IBM stock.
Well here you are some money there and you buy some bitcoin with it.
Whoa.
So traditional brokerages deal in Bitcoin as well.
No,
this is a specialized exchange that deals in Bitcoin,
but it works just like a brokerage account.
So you have a number of different currencies in it and you can buy one and sell
the other.
Are there any brokers who deal in bitcoins,
uh,
of like traditional,
large scale?
No,
not yet.
Not yet.
But you think that's coming?
Oh,
absolutely.
Yeah.
Because the thing is,
it's,
it's a,
it's one of the skills they have,
right?
They also have the physical locations and branches to sell bed coin and before
long board,
we're going to see as the same thing that happened in the entertainment
industry.
When MP3 hit the scene.
Like at first everyone was like,
Whoa,
we don't want to even touch this.
And then somebody started thinking,
Hey,
if I start playing with this before everybody else,
it's going to hurt all of us,
but it's going to hurt me less than I can start taking advantage.
And they peel off the herd and boom,
you have adoption.
And I think the same thing is going to start happening with banking.
Wow.
Some of the banks,
perhaps not the big six US banks,
they've got a nice,
uh,
comfortable,
$70 billion a month from the Fed right now.
Why would they do innovation?
But maybe one of the more nimble banks may be,
you know,
in,
in a country like Cyprus that's been hit hard by these bail ins and you have a
very open banking environment.
Maybe Singapore is going to decide this is a good strategic move.
May Been Mccall who knows.
The point is in an international financial environment,
all it takes is one.
Yeah.
One ball gets rolling and then creates the avalanche and then,
and then the stem piece and then the standard changes.
Right.
Wow.
This is very exciting.
It's very complex though.
And this is what I'm trying to wrap my head around.
The,
the amount of this bitcoin that's created every year is limited in fixed.
Who determined all of this?
Who Do,
who created bitcoin?
Who invented the concept?
Was there several people or,
yeah,
you said when you exchanged money it's,
it's almost free.
I heard.
So that money goes somewhere.
Who's getting this money?
So this is where it gets a bit more complicated.
And,
um,
but keep in mind the internet in 1992,
you had to know unix command line skills to send an email and it took two days
across the network.
We can get simpler and easier for most people over time,
but it's still a bit geeky.
So I'll,
I'll,
I'll get into it.
One question at a time though.
Who created this?
So this was created by Satoshi Nakamoto,
a cryptographer who used an anonymous identity or pseudonymous identity.
Uh,
he,
he basically wrote a paper and the basic software,
a scientific paper that explains how it works.
It's actually the best way to understand bitcoin.
If you have a bit of understanding of,
of basic science,
you can,
you can read it.
It's very accessible.
And if you look for those Satoshi Nakamoto bitcoin paper or the bitcoin paper,
you'll find it online.
Um,
so he wrote a paper and at the same time he created the software that runs the
system,
right?
And then gave it out to people and people started running it.
Now keep in mind,
bitcoin is an agreement.
It's a standard.
It's how you do certain things on the bitcoin network that's matters,
right?
And then there's software that implements that agreement.
The runs according to those rules,
just like the internet doesn't belong to anyone,
is just an agreement of how you transmit things across the Internet.
And then everybody can write software that can use that standard.
So Satoshi Nakamoto created the standards in 2008,
2008.
The paper came out in 2008 and followed shortly thereafter by the code.
The discussion actually lasted about a here as he was mulling this over and
discussing it.
And keep in mind,
digital money is not new.
We've been doing digital money since the probably the mid eighties.
I think the first,
a notable one was David showmes,
Digi cash and he created a form of digital money using the new technology of
cryptography at the time.
Um,
he and cryptography is,
is a way of scrambling and unscrambling messages and doing digital signatures
and using mathematics to,
to prove things basically on computers.
It's also what you use to protect your browsing session when you connect to your
bank and it puts that little lock that's using cryptography,
you're doing an an an encrypted session.
So at the time,
uh,
David Chaum basically created additional money.
And what it is is you can have a number that has a signature on it,
the proof's who owns it.
And then you can spend that.
The problem is that you,
because it's digital,
you can copy it.
So what happens if you spend it twice?
Well,
you have to have some kind of central authority,
the checks to see that you don't spend it twice.
And so he put some servers together and they could handle all of the
transactions and make sure nobody spent the money twice and issue the money into
all of the kind of Federal Reserve Central Bank functions and then ran it on the
network and it worked.
So unfortunately,
if you have a central server and you try to go against the banking system,
they stomp on you.
So they stomp on you.
In this case,
uh,
there,
there was a series of legal battles and then eventually the service got down.
And so we've seen this happen maybe four or five times with different attempts
to do digital cash with various levels of centralization.
But the basic problem was this,
how do you ensure that the network remains trusted and honest
without having someone in the middle who checks everything and authority?
How do you put trust?
Not In an institution or central authority as most hierarchal system work,
but in a con,
but spread that trust across the whole network.
And in 2008,
Satoshi Nakamoto solve that problem and he solved it by putting together four or
five ideas that each of them had been done somewhat
before,
but he put them together in an incredible combination that just worked and
worked beautifully.
So what the system does is it forces everyone who's participating on the network
to do a bit of a computing,
um,
with our system,
which is called mining.
And so if you,
if you just have a wallet,
you don't do this,
but if you want to be part of the bitcoin network as a minor,
what you do is you run on a specialized computer and it solves this very
difficult problem.
And it's kind of like a competition.
It's like looking for a magical number is that,
that if you plug it into an equation,
it's,
it's the right number.
It's,
it's almost like a global competition,
like solving a giant Sudoku puzzle.
So everyone's trying,
and then somebody,
every 10 minutes on average finds a solution and that becomes a new block of
transactions.
And when they find that solution,
they get some bitcoin,
which is new.
Bitcoin is created for the first time.
I'm confused.
Yeah,
I know.
Find a solution for what?
All right.
So basically the idea is everybody's trying to find a way to create a new block
of transactions,
right?
And in this block they also get a reward for creating the block.
What is a block of transactions?
It's basically,
um,
it's basically a,
an entry on the ledger.
So,
as I mentioned before,
there's,
um,
there's a way to have,
there's a central transaction ledger where you can see everybody's transactions.
In order to write on that,
in order to create a new transaction to the entire network trusts,
you have to solve a very difficult problem.
Right.
But if you do solve the problem,
you get a reward in bitcoin.
When you say you solved the problem,
is someone physically sitting in front of their computer trying to solve the
problem of the computers?
The shooter,
yeah.
Okay.
So their computer,
you're using their CPU power.
Yes.
But essentially,
yes,
exactly.
Okay.
So runs in the background,
it's called commercial of work.
You do a,
you're run a program that does proof of work,
which is basically solving this difficult problem.
So is this in some way like sort of similar in fact to how Bitcoin,
how bit torrent works,
where bid corn bid torrent you,
you leave it on like if you're a sh a file share,
like how bands can spread their music that way they put their files online,
let people know where there are,
then people seed it and then they all just,
every,
every bitcoin wallet works like that.
It's like a little bit torrent clients and it talks to all the wallets and
confined on the,
on the network and communicates.
But there are some specialized systems which,
which do this computation problem very,
very fast and they're big and noisy and have lots of fans because it's gotten
very competitive.
So people upgraded their stuff and then they upgraded it again and then they
upgrade it again.
And it's caused this kind of an arms race of computing power.
But the basic idea is that you,
you,
you buy a box that has this ability to solve the problem.
You plug it into the network and it runs and it chews up electricity and it
glides bitcoin.
A dedicated box to try to help solve
this,
and in the meantime it makes money.
Yeah,
and it makes a bit of money.
And people join in groups that are called pools,
just like playing a lottery.
Put this while I look.
This guy,
this guy is,
this is his servers.
These are all the Bitcoin solvers,
if I'm not mistaken.
This is a,
yeah,
this is a liquid cool.
A rack system for folks who haven't seen this photo,
if you're listening to this,
which is the majority of our people,
what are they googling?
Brian?
What's the image?
Coin Mining.
It's the first one.
Jesus fucking Christ.
You have to see this picture folks,
when you get home.
Bitcoin mining,
they have goddamn rooms filled with computers that they're making bitcoin when
we're in the matrix.
So we're here,
let me just,
Damn Matrix.
Holy Shit.
This is crazy.
There's somebody's house.
So the bitcoin network today is bigger than the world's top several hundred
super computers combined.
It's the largest single computing experiment on the Internet ever.
What's using more internet juice,
bitcoin or porn at the moment?
Bitcoin.
That's not possible,
son.
You're talking crazy,
but it's also a,
it's also generating an entire new economy based on that.
How much prostitution has been paid for in Bitcoin.
Is that possible?
I have no ideas.
Are you sure?
100% sure that.
Wow.
No,
you're just guessing.
You're not 100% sure.
You're pretty sure you can't say out of all the people on the road that's sluts
or one uses super peak sloughed.
What if you find the first one today?
All right.
Let me give you an argument for why that might touch.
That makes sense.
If you're a sex worker,
one of the problems better world have is you're going to get extorted and
exploited for that money and you're not going to keep any of it.
With a bitcoin wallet,
you can basically hide that money and you can also take it in a way that cannot
be taken away from you,
not easily.
So you know there's just take your phone.
Nope,
not so easy.
No.
Because it's backed up and,
right,
exactly.
Yeah.
I mean you're not carrying physical cash.
It's a much safer exchange.
And so there are many reasons why in many different environments where money is
difficult,
uh,
that bitcoin is successful.
And here's the thing,
bitcoin is very efficient money.
It's a very good system of money.
If you can send money like an email anywhere in the world will,
yeah,
it's tremendously useful.
And so in places,
and that includes criminal activities where it's difficult to move money.
Bitcoin is going to be good for that.
Regulate the point because at the end of the day,
there's another 6 billion of us want to do good things with it.
And just like on the Internet,
you can use it for crime,
but it gives so much more to humanity.
Of course you can use bitcoin for crime you can use,
but the reality is US dollars are used for crime.
The currency in the Washington prostitution is the most ridiculous crime ever.
It's so should be legal.
It's so that people can
have sex for free,
but they can't have sex for money.
How come you give him,
give massages for money and massages?
A prostitution.
Okay.
They are,
they might as well be prostitution.
They're awesome.
Don't get me wrong,
I love massages,
but it's fucking prostitution.
The person doesn't want to rub you,
whether it's a guy or a girl,
you want them to rub you,
you give them money,
they rub you.
They even pretend.
They like rubbing you.
They bring you water,
they get you a towel.
They don't give a fuck about that towel.
Bullshit.
Come on man.
That's the,
that's part of the Gig.
Part of the,
that's the part of the prostitution gig.
The idea that in 2014 it's still illegal to pay someone for sex is so stupid.
Not even handjobs nothing.
No Penis.
Can't touch it.
It's a bad place.
It's a bad place and you can't have money involved in your bad place.
It's like paying money for crime.
You call it crime.
I just found out.
Yes,
it's being used for prostitution.
Uh,
the first one was September of this year or last year.
Passion,
VIP and escort agency in England.
Since they had,
now I've accepted bitcoins as payment,
godspeed to you,
passionate Gip in England,
Godspeed to you.
So now we know that kind of crime,
but let's,
let's separate ourselves from such controversial talk because this could really
screw people's up.
Their idea of what bitcoin really is.
No,
I mean,
here's the thing.
Bitcoin is not just money,
but when is an invention and what that invention allows people to do is move
value across the Internet.
And that invention means you can do bitcoin,
but it also means you can do a lot of other things.
And bitcoin is an incredible invention because it,
for the first time,
it completely democratized,
democratizes money.
It's separates money from a function of power of the state to an individual
exchange between people like it's used to be when it was shells and feathers,
right?
Or um,
you know,
barter exchange.
But the beauty of it is that it can,
at the moment,
if you think about it,
there is,
let's say a billion people in the western world who have not just banking
facilities,
but like turbocharged power banking.
They have international transactions.
They can buy stocks on any stock market.
They can do wire transfers,
some of them are credited investors,
et cetera.
The power user of banking,
there's another may be 2 billion people who have a basic bank account and then
there's the rest of them,
right?
The,
the giant majority of the population on this planet has very limited access to
banking,
very limited access to international finance,
to lending,
to capitol,
to uh,
the ability to even change their money to another currency.
And so bitcoin is so much more important for them.
I call this the other 6 billion just keeps the focus on the other 6 billion
because for the billion it might be a fad,
but for the other 6 billion,
this is an opportunity to change the way we deal with poverty and to change the
way we unite the economic system of the planet,
which is a whole other level of compensation.
It will look at bitcoin and we think of it as
just money,
but it's not just money for the Internet.
Money for the Internet is what it does.
And it does it very well.
But it's the intranet of money and it allows people at the edge by downloading
just a simple application to join an economy and then to hold their own money
without any state or corporation.
Being able to steal it from them or inflated how to value and destroy their
children's future.
It allows them to hold and control that money and send it to anyone in the
world.
They want to instantly for very little money.
I mean that's never happened before and the implications that has for poverty,
for did the developing world for the way non governmental organizations work is
staggering.
Just take one example.
International remittances at the moment,
500 or so billion dollars cent every year from the first world,
two countries in the developing world,
right.
And out of that money,
74 billion gets spent in fees,
fees as high as 30 or 40% in fact,
the poor of the country,
the higher the percentage of fee you have to pay.
So Somalia and my migrants in the u s who sending $100 home,
only 70 gets to the,
to the,
to the wife or the brother back home or the husband back home and the rest gets
chewed out by the money transfer companies.
Now we give the developed world 150 or so billion and then we to the richest and
hope it trickles down and then we take 74 billion from the poorest.
What if we could change that?
What if we could enable bitcoin remittances and international payments and
redeliver that 74 billion of their money and allow them to send that money
directly home without paying that fee?
That changes the lives of a billion people.
Wow.
So you envisioned bitcoin as being a universal currency.
Absolutely.
It already is.
Will it absorb the dollar or the,
will the dollar go away with a doll coexist along with bitcoin?
Like what is your hope for this?
Well,
I mean I think that like many disruptive technologies is going to change the
power balance.
It's not that the dollar goes away of the banking system,
goes away,
it just has less power and less relevance in a new world where people control
their own money and can send it to each other.
So ultimately the grand hope is that the money,
the dollar that we see today becomes in the future.
Much like the written letter,
no fucking need it anymore.
You can send emails,
you send someone a text message,
you have to get on a fucking pony and carry your mail over to another state.
Yes.
And the thing is,
the dollar again is the world reserve currency.
And there's only one of it.
Now are there 193 other currencies that,
that some of them may end up getting replaced?
Uh,
some of them may end up even converting into cryptocurrencies.
Have a nation states,
you know,
like,
I don't know,
Thailand coin,
why not?
Or Fed coin if we're doing it here.
But the point is that we can't judge bitcoin on the standard of the most
comfortable world reserve currency.
That's the most stable currents we have to look at the rest of the world.
And see what their currencies are like.
And in many cars,
countries,
the currency is worth less than goat shit because you can burn goat shed longer
than you can burn these bundles of paper money that doesn't burn very well,
you know,
and in in those countries,
this is not a matter of shopping.
This is a matter of of the future of their children and it's a matter of
development.
Wow,
that's,
that's really fascinating.
It's,
it's one of the concerns as far as security.
What are the concerns as far as if someone steals your bitcoins,
is there any sort of a regulatory body that can determine whether or not
someone's computer or phones been hacked into and their big bitcoin's had been
stolen?
I mean I have,
has that become an issue yet or is that a potential issue?
It is a potential issue and it has become an issue and yeah,
people have had their bitcoin stolen.
You,
how has that happened?
What is their computer gets hacked and then they have a password on the account,
but they don't have like,
um,
you know,
one of the things you can do very easily is set up what's called two factor
authentication.
So every time you tried to use your bitcoin wallet,
it sends you a little text message and you have to enter the secret code like
you do with your bank height.
Slightly higher on the socio computer's been hacked.
They don't get the text messages,
they can't easily get into your account.
What does that,
that article you just brought up,
Brian,
this is the latest hack.
I know that Bitcoin has been hacked a few times,
but this last one was one point $2 million.
And there's an article on wired called 1.2 million hacks shows why you should
never store bitcoins on the Internet.
Uh,
what,
what happens to something like that?
That they just lost this,
right?
There's no,
there's no getting this back.
And,
and is there somebody that like a group of people that um,
that you think is responsible for this or?
Well,
no,
I mean there's always been a,
a thriving hacker underground that a,
that he uses the most efficient way to steal money.
And so they stole money from targets by compromising all of those credit cards
just a few weeks ago.
And that affected her a lot more people than any of these thefts.
And you know that they're going to go after wherever the money is.
And if the efficient money is bitcoin,
they're going to go after bitcoin too.
But here's the trick,
because this money is controlled through mathematical security and because it's
programmable,
we can actually create new ways of securing money so we can innovate,
whether it's the paper wallet example I gave you,
where you can create a physical copy that you can secure old style in a safe
deposit box,
whether it's using multisignature transactions,
where for example,
the money is locked and it takes,
uh,
two keys or three keys to unlock it.
So for example,
you can have a backup company that provides the second key.
And so if you lose the primary key,
you could use the secondary key.
You can do digital backups,
you can do,
you can do time locks,
you can do all kinds of things now with money because it's programmable that
allow you to create new ways of securing it.
So it's still very early,
early days.
Um,
you know,
some,
some people who don't take care put too much of their bitcoin in one place and
yeah,
that's not a very good idea.
They have weak passwords.
So in this happened,
when these people lost 1.2 million in Bitcoin,
there's no bringing that back.
There's no tracing it.
There's no find out where it went or their social securities and these bitcoins
or numbers rather than these bitcoins that nope,
like dollar bills,
you know,
they'd trace like back
it's cash.
No,
it's because it's digital.
I mean,
this is one of the key,
um,
one of the key controls in the system is that it's like teleporting the digital
cash and you know,
once it,
it's not on your Tele Porter pad and it's gone,
you just hope the other teleporter we'll send it back to you.
Cause otherwise it's gone.
I mean it's digital cash.
It can go very easily because it flows very easily.
Um,
so what we're doing at the moment is developing new security techniques to make
it both harder to steal in the,
in the first place to have backups so that you can,
um,
so they couldn't get back if a,
if a key stolen before it's used and there's all kinds of things we can do to
make this better.
It's still early days.
There was a story about that guy who left his bitcoin on his hard drive and
tossed it out accidentally and it's worth $9 million.
Right.
I'm sure you're aware of that story.
Yeah.
This was in,
uh,
this was,
an England and throughout the,
actually all that happened is that a lot of people showed up at the local
landfill with a,
with metal detectors.
So a lot of people were looking for this treasure hunters.
Again,
we're trying to steal it.
Well,
digital treasure hunting is going to be a thing,
a part of our future.
Yeah.
So you've got,
people are going to like find old hard drives.
When my 2013 and I looked for bitcoins on them,
well I love stories like this.
I was on Reddit the other day and I was reading this great story.
This student who said,
you know,
back in 2010 I did some bitcoin mining on my laptop and I just found that wallet
and it says,
I have 917 bitcoin.
Am I rich or am I missing something because this would really change my life.
I've got student loans and the guy had,
you know,
at the time it was a $900,000 worth of bitcoin that he had found from a laptop.
He left laying around in 2010 and did some mining,
and that story is great and it's happened many,
many times.
So did it,
that guy sell that and become like almost a millionaire.
Yup.
That's insane.
And this was a student who was like,
I'm having trouble with my student loans.
You know,
this could really help me.
Am I too am I?
He couldn't believe it.
He was like,
I might see this wrong.
That's from mining.
So,
okay,
let's,
let's
good crazy talking monkey studios here.
We decided to start a mining up.
Don't,
don't,
don't know.
I mean it's the high trying to win $1 million.
It's like,
I'm sorry,
which tells me we don't know so well,
I'll sign.
I had it figured out.
So the,
the,
the reason people have been successful with bitcoin is because they got
interested in the technology went only a few thousand people knew about it and
when they got involved,
at that point,
bitcoins were worth like a hundredth of a penny or a thousandth of a penny and
now they're worth a $2.
So if you ended up mining some,
then even if you only mind a few,
you know,
plus it was a lot easier to mind then because over time the network adjust the
difficulty.
So the more people trying,
the harder it gets.
So the network is autonomous,
there's no centralized server,
there's no central anything.
It's,
it's a series of rules that everybody follows and it's hard to grasp at first
because we've never seen this type of distributed organization.
And is there any organization whatsoever as far as like a CEO,
Doris,
does that money go then every time the transaction goes?
Is it good just Atashi Nakamoto?
No,
no,
no.
If they even exist,
there's not even a real picture of him anywhere on the Internet and no one's
actually ever confirmed his identity.
So it could be just the government
or anonymous.
It's an invisible hacker visit,
physically invisible.
So all of the people who are doing the mining who have the,
the,
the hardware in a,
using it to mine for Bitcoin,
what they do is they secure the network by running this very hard problem.
They prevent anyone else from cheating because in order to essentially they end
up voting on every block together with this enormous computing power and that
enormous computing power means no one can falsify the block because they would
have to do that much computing power to falsify the the ledger,
right?
So if you can't falsify it without doing enormous amounts of computing power,
but if you do enormous amounts of computing power that you get a reward and
bitcoin while you're going to try and win the game rather than cheat cheating is
extremely difficult and not rewarding.
Whereas participating is rewarding.
I see.
Right.
So all of these miners are working and what they do is they verify the
transactions and they secure the entire network,
which actually if you look at it on the grand scheme of things,
is a lot cheaper than guards and armored trucks and alarm companies and faults
and data centers and fraud prevention center is,
and all of those things that we have in our traditional payment system,
it's actually a lot cheaper to do it by proving you're doing all of this
computation for the network security.
Now they collect fees.
So when they verify a block,
the person who manages the verify at first by finding this little magic number,
the solution to the problem,
I'll explain that in a second,
collects the fees that are in the block.
So all of the transactions that get verified.
Then the next 10 minutes,
the miner who finds that block will collect all of the little fees.
40 cents here,
40 cents they are 40 cents there.
It's about 40 40 cents to send a simple transaction right now and they'll also
get a reward of 25 bitcoin and then everyone will start the race again to,
to verify the next block of transactions for the next 10 minutes of spending.
And the first one to find the solution wins gets the reward,
gets the fees and they all start competing again.
But you don't know who's going to win it.
And the enormous amount of computation that goes into its ensures that no one
can cheat.
Even if you put together the 600 most powerful supercomputers in the world,
you would not be able to get to to beat the system right now.
What a fascinating element to be added to the idea of the economy.
This,
this idea of the unified group of computers working on ever increasingly complex
computations.
So the scientific term for it is a consensus assets ledger,
which means it's a lighter or list of transactions about assets.
In this case,
bitcoin that's based on consensus on agreement and the agreement is reached by
everyone voting with their computing power.
And because there's so much of it,
you can't cheat the election.
Now,
when you said that there have been other attempts at a new type of currency that
had been shut down by the current banking system,
that was because they had a place where they had centralized servers exactly
operated or the centralized service
or a centralized organization or a centralized something.
What did they do to stop it?
That movie?
Is there any legality issues when it comes to doing something like this or
creating a new type of currency?
Oh sure.
Oh,
there's this,
there's an enormous legality issues.
I mean the banking system has this fortress wall of regulations around it that
acts partly supposedly to protect consumers from misbehaving banks but also
serves very well to prevent competition from small banks because it's very
expensive to do to,
you know,
pass all the tests.
Right,
right.
Say keeps the RAF the rabble out,
but uh,
you know,
then a lot of the criminals end up being inside this whole system here.
Here's the thing that,
that whole regulatory system comes down hard on people who had decided to want
to create their own currency.
And the Nice thing about bitcoin is that there is no one there.
I mean,
basically in agreement when you say comes down hard,
like in what manner?
Like how,
how would they come down hard?
Like let's say you just asset forfeiture,
seizures,
lawsuits,
a money laundering charges,
all kinds of things like that.
And this is because you're not doing things by regulation,
is that what you're saying?
Well,
it has happened that way in the past.
So you no matter what,
what if you decide to create your own currency and you have an actual business
and you were a centralized business that essentially be centralized.
Business is responsible for following all of the government standards on banking
100% across the board.
And if you don't,
that's where money laundering charges,
larceny and a lot of different
charges get brought up is that,
that's what goes on now that's avoided somehow or another through bitcoin
because of the voided.
It's simply the bitcoin is a completely decentralized system.
It works based on math.
So there is no,
there's no one running bitcoin.
It was an invention just like someone invented electricity than we all learned
how it worked and we all ended up using it.
But does it matter who you know,
invented the electricity that makes us light work?
No.
Bitcoin is like that.
It's a standard.
It's an idea and it runs by people participating in the network.
So there's nothing,
there is no central location,
there's no company behind it,
there's no leader,
there's nothing.
It's a decentralized,
it's just like no one runs the Internet.
So if you say,
I don't want the Internet to do this,
who are
you gonna sue?
It's a global network.
Yeah.
I mean what Al Gore Al Gore for inventing it.
Why it's,
well that's one of the reasons to Toshi Nakamoto disappeared because he was
smart enough to know that uh,
you know,
smearing him would affect bitcoin but couldn't he could since he programmed
everything,
have access to everybody's money if he wanted to know.
So let me explain that.
The software itself is so called open source software.
That means that it's a recipe of code that implements the,
the big coin agreement according to the network standards.
And you can write your own,
I mean if you don't want to run that software you can write a version of it.
In fact,
there are five or six different,
um,
you know,
fully compliant versions that can participate in the network.
And even if you take the basic one that started with him writing it,
but since has involved in a community project with lots of people writing code,
you know,
just like the intranet,
it,
you just agree to play by the rules.
And then you can read the code and you can see exactly what happens.
There is no controls in there.
There's no magic secret keys.
You can see how it works.
What do you,
what are you saying?
Hold on a second.
There's five or six different types of bitcoin.
There's,
there's five or six different programs that can,
that can do the full bitcoin,
uh,
language on the bitcoin network.
Five or six different versions,
but they all speak bitcoin so it doesn't matter.
But what are they doing differently than the other ones?
Just um,
different ways,
different programming languages,
different ways of implementing them.
Some are more efficient in some ways.
Some are more efficient than the others,
but they don't do anything different in terms of bitcoin.
So there's just like,
there are lots of different internet routers and they all speak TCP Ip on the
internets and you know,
Cisco makes some [inaudible] juniper networks make some others in HP makes them
others,
but they all speak the same.
I see.
So there's no concern whatsoever.
There's any security openings because of the fact that these guys are producing
their own software.
That communicates in big,
right?
Because the trust is based on computation,
not taxes.
So this is a key thing to realize all of our payment systems and banking systems
up to now keep trust in the system by keeping people out,
by controlling very carefully who connects to the network.
And that means the network is always very small.
In bitcoin,
all of the trust is done by this joint computation,
right?
And so who talks the network doesn't matter because the network is trusted and
safe regardless of what you try to send to it or receive from it or how you
interpret it because there's no center.
So this has radical implications because that means you can let anyone talk to
the network or rather you can let everyone talk to the network and everyone can
be a bank on that network and everyone can send wires,
transfers on that network power of a bank on your smartphone.
And as long as it speaks to the bitcoin language and understands it with the
rest of the network,
you don't need to trust,
you know it,
that that
application is running.
The trust happens in the transactions in the network,
you can't cheat no matter what you do.
Right?
So what is the motivation to write a new software?
What does the mode
fish,
it's like there are different pieces that all run windows.
There's you know,
different clients that all run picc line.
I see.
So they just have to sit at decided to run their own program that that speaks
bitcoin but it participates in the exact same fashion.
Right?
You have a chrome browser or you have a Firefox browser or why there too,
right?
Same thing.
Okay.
In fact it's very similar or like a bit torrent client.
There are three different versions,
but they all speak bitterns and your brows is all speak http,
the hypertext transfer protocol.
So no matter what website you go to,
and there are lots of websites,
programs that made by different companies that speak the server side of the web.
You know,
there's lots of different versions.
But what matters is the common language they speak.
And bitcoin is like that.
It's a common language,
a protocol or standard.
And that means that no matter what you attached to the network,
whether it's a a wallet that's written for Androids,
a wallet that's written for Iphone or a wallet that's fancier or a wallet
that's,
that's more geeky.
All of these will speak Bitcoin to the network and we'll work with a system and
the trust is in the network.
Now,
when we were talking earlier about the,
if you had a centralized location,
centralized server that can be shut down by the banks and they could charge you
with all these crimes,
is there any concern legally speaking that if you were a person who has all your
money in bitcoin that maybe one day the government could come along and say,
bitcoin is not a valid currency,
it's illegal to use using it as a crime and we find it on you,
we're going to take it from you and we're going to arrest you?
Well,
actually,
yeah.
Government has already said that bitcoin is legal and that users using bitcoin
are are doing perfectly legal business.
Can you pay taxes in Bitcoin?
I'm not directly,
no.
You'd have to convert it to dollars,
but as a company that will take your bitcoin and pay the taxes for you.
Bingo.
So,
um,
uh,
back in April,
the fin cen,
which is the financial crimes enforcement network,
uh,
created a memorandum where it explains how we treat bitcoin.
And it said,
you know,
if you're just an individual using bitcoin to buy and sell things,
great.
It's just like anything else you,
you're going to pay,
uh,
you know you're going to pay your transaction.
And that's it.
If you're someone who makes a living in Bitcoin,
you pay income tax.
And if you're someone who's mining on Bitcoin,
you pay income tax on those bitcoins.
So if you're an investor,
you pay capital gains.
It's treated just like any other currency.
So if you make your living off Bitcoin,
that's how you get paid.
You convert that to dollars,
then you pay a percentage in dollars.
Is that what you should do?
You convert like how much you made in Bitcoin coin in the year and what that
would be in dollar bills and then pay the percentage on that.
Right.
But I mean that's not different
from what I did before.
When I got paid in euros.
I mean occasionally I get a paycheck from a customer in Europe.
They're going to pay me in euro's,
right?
What do you do?
You convert it to dollars.
You mark the rates at which they paid you,
you know,
you invoiced them,
they paid you in euros,
you mark what rate it was,
and then you put it on the tax return as income.
People are notoriously bad about reporting income when you know,
when it's independent,
when they're not being taxed by their employer,
when it's not coming directly out of their paycheck.
Comedians are terrible about that.
I know so many comedians that have had like serious IRS problems because of
that.
I would think that that sort of issue would arise with bitcoin where people are
responsible for paying taxes on these and they don't.
I mean,
how much,
how much of an issue is that and how much of a criminality issue could that
become?
Well,
I I think has al Capone found out there was one thing you can too in the u s and
that's not pay your taxes.
They might get,
they might not get you for anything else.
You pull it up,
right.
I keep pulling up these orders,
I pay my taxes and uh,
and if you earn money in Bitcoin,
you pay your taxes on Bitcoin is simple as death.
And if you think you can get away with not doing that,
then you'll find out like many people before you that the IRS will come,
will audit you and you will end up paying a lot more.
Yeah.
Even if you want to pay them back and agree to pay them back,
they still put you in jail.
So yeah,
I don't think you need to sit in a cage for a little while and think about what
you did.
I mean,
the,
that would simply be a monumentally stupid sink to do,
uh,
to think that somehow that would protect.
No,
I mean they're going to track down your accounts just as effectively with
bitcoin as they deal with other things.
They're not stupid.
What are these articles you keep pulling up?
Brian,
just keep on finding new things about different news reports.
Like this was a four hours ago where two guys have been arrested a major,
a prominent players in the bitcoin universe.
Charles Sherman was arrested by federal prosecutors on Sunday and accused of
helping grease the wheels for drug transactions,
you know,
uh,
using bitcoins and uh,
Mr Shrem was also the founder and chief executive of popular website called bit
instant.
We're bitcoins could be bought using dollars.
And so what it seems like there's a lot of people getting arrested though.
There was another guy that I flashed up earlier that was arrested.
It seems like there's a lot of shady stuff going on in this universe right now.
Honestly,
that's the only reason I never went and got into bitcoins.
You don't feel nervous about all these like recent news things at all or cause
you seem very pro like I,
I'm not worried about it at all.
Stated playstation that people are not going to stop going online and shopping
on amazon.com of Amazon gets hacked.
What you're dealing with is a few people that are scumbags,
that are operating in this a truly revolutionary system that is very beneficial.
Yeah.
But this is like hitting send counselors.
There's bank,
this is like robbing a bank,
you know.
Well,
no,
in this whole,
so here's my perspective.
Um,
bitcoin is a,
technology is
powerful and is being used by school teachers to manage a PTA groups.
It's been used by churches to manage tithing and their collection plates.
And there are clubs and it's also being used by criminals occasionally to do
crimes just like any other currency.
In fact,
the,
the point is that compared to another currency like the dollar,
uh,
you know,
the,
the money laundering that happens with a dollar,
I mean,
HSBC was found and convicted under consent agreements,
I think for $17 billion of money laundering with the worst Mexican cartels.
And they got a minor fine and no one went to jail.
And what Cocoavia was money laundering,
hundreds of billions of dollars with,
uh,
with,
various drug cartels in Asia.
And again,
nothing happened.
So let's not pretend that suddenly bitcoin is like this criminal,
uh,
situation.
It's not,
it just represents just like the Internet represents society and you get the
whole spectrum.
Bitcoin as a currency can be used for economic activity and that means the whole
spectrum.
And you'll have a small subset who are people who take advantage and then you
have the vast majority.
Increasingly now it's getting more mainstream.
I see the possibility of being able to do exciting new things with money that
weren't possible before and,
and to enable new forms of commerce.
You know,
there are hundreds of startups that are innovating with new forms of,
for example,
how to do settlement and escrow on a real estate transaction and not spend 2% on
that but do it with bitcoin much more safely,
much more effectively.
Companies that are working on doing charitable foundations based on Bitcoin
endowments,
charities that are working to do remittances to foreign countries to help the
poor people.
You know,
all kinds of activities are happening.
But what is the primary focus of the media?
It is to generate page views and you know,
portraying the sensationalist stuff always wins out.
So there's a lot more to bitcoin.
Don't get fooled by the fact that,
you know,
some,
some things are emphasized as if that's the be all.
And Adult Ed Coyle was certainly some things are emphasized,
but those are legitimate stories.
I mean,
that was a legitimate story that the stores are arrested for.
You can't judge the media on reporting legitimate crimes.
No,
I don't think that's the,
that's the issue.
The problem is,
you know,
you get a lot more of that than,
than is actually occurring and you get a lot less of the stuff.
That's really interesting and important in my view.
The positive stories.
Positive stories.
Exactly.
And you know,
the way I look at Bitcoin,
I think about the possibility you can create jobs.
I look at it as a technological innovation.
I look at it as an engine for growth in a stagnant economy,
you know,
so,
so those are the things that stick in my mind.
Jobs,
innovation and growth.
Not,
you know,
the
fact that,
uh,
some bad dude used bitcoin to do bad things.
Your,
your example of the bank that was laundering money with the drug cartels is
absolutely perfect because that barely got a peep out of people.
And that was a very recent decision.
And you know,
I mean,
I saw some outrage from a few Twitter users.
I literally,
I've read the story and my mouth was hanging open.
I was like,
how could they get away with that and just get a fine,
like they dealt with murderers and they laundered their drug money and they did
it for a long time and they made a lot of money.
Yeah.
And they just got a slap
wasn't even up to the par of the money they made.
That's the shocking thing.
It's not even covering the profits they lost,
which basically rewards and says,
yeah,
go ahead,
do it again.
You made a great return on that investment.
There's a real issue with this whole Mexican drug war is that there's so much
money to be made and being a part of it and it leaves so many holes open for
corruption.
And even legal corruption,
like this type of stuff where it's,
it's they do something,
they get fined by whatever regulatory body,
but yet they're still in business.
They're still,
they're enacting in the profit on that decision,
encouraging,
literally encouraging people to continue to do business with illegal groups like
that.
If you can make that kind of profit,
which you know,
there's a real issue in this country,
a massive amount of distrust of law enforcement and there's a big part of that
becomes,
uh,
it comes out of the war on drugs.
It comes out of the war on nicknamed the drug.
You know,
whether it's cocaine or whether all these different people that are struggling
to keep things illegal are pumping up all these businesses that sell these
illegal drugs because there's this massive demand for it.
So when you see a war on drugs,
w w what's you're seeing is,
is an engine to generate money for crime.
That's all it is.
People are not going to stop altering their consciousness,
but you are ensuring that the people that are profiting off of that are going to
be criminals.
And then it leaves the door open for people who are in,
in actual law enforcement to see these loopholes and see these these ways.
They could skim a little money to take a little bit home for themselves.
And next thing you know,
you got corruption and next thing you go,
you got bankers going,
listen,
I can guarantee you the worst going to happen is we're going to get a fine if I
was going to be little and we're going to make a fuck load of money.
And these guys Pedro's coming over and he's got a donkey cart.
Well this,
this is the best part of the story in,
in one of these bank,
uh,
situations where they had these branches and Mexico and they were putting
literally millions of dollars in suitcases,
a stake in them through the teller window.
They actually ended up designing and mass manufacturing suitcases that fits
through the slot because they were doing it every single day.
So they had a teller window slot fitting briefcase so they could stuff that cash
through
and no one went to jail.
Wow,
that's amazing.
So,
you know,
I mean,
we can talk about money all day and some money.
We'll create situations for people to take advantage.
Absolutely.
Well it does the way with guns,
it's good.
Does that we were everything.
I mean that's that whole,
um,
that fast and furious investigation that you know about that there was a worthy
whatever government agency was selling arms to Mexican drug dealers so that they
can quote unquote track the guns.
You know?
And it's ridiculous because those guns actually got used for killing American
service members,
American,
the people that were involved in border patrol,
people that were involved in law enforcement,
a lot of these,
uh,
these guns wound up being used to actually kill Americans more than one.
And
the idea behind it is so preposterous.
The idea that you're going to sell weapons to criminals so that you could track
where these weapons go.
Like,
no,
that's a fucking terrible idea.
These are the people that are in charge of deciding,
you know,
what kind of laws get enforced and what w what atmosphere of law enforcement
this,
this country has.
And when you see things like that,
it's so frustrating and confusing because it seems almost like a Palladian
crime.
Like someone's solds sold some guns to these Mexican drug lords and they did it
under the guise of this crazy operation.
We're just going to sell them guns and keep an eye on them that way.
We'll track them and then we're going to get them that way.
You're giving them guns like that's what they want.
That's what they need to perform crimes.
You're giving them tools.
It's like a guy who's a fucking carpenter.
You're giving them a saw and a hammer.
You're giving it to him and you're literally telling them to go use them.
I mean,
that's essentially what you're doing and you're profiting off that.
How was,
how were you not in jail for selling guns?
How do you,
how can you say that?
That was a,
uh,
an idea,
a plan that you had?
I mean,
it's unbelievable.
It's unbelievable and it's in,
it's impossible to,
to read those stories and,
and,
and understand how we could ever trust the people that are in charge of,
of,
of running this country.
If this is something you're capable of doing,
how the fuck can anybody trust you?
How could anybody ever take your leadership seriously if this is what you do?
This is madness.
Well,
I mean that's one of the reasons that I think a lot of people are also
passionate about Bitcoin is that they've realized,
especially since 2008 that these same people cannot be trusted to run the money
system.
And we've seen now for the last,
for example,
five years,
the Fed has been printing between 85 now tapered down to about $70 billion a
month and giving it as corporate welfare and direct subsidies to the banks.
So we didn't get a stimulus,
but they are continuing for five years now to remain solvent based on $70
billion a month.
That's $1 trillion a year,
almost in dollars generated by the Fed.
Most people don't even know this is happening.
These little people running our,
and what it means is
that you go out to use your dollars at the store and suddenly you can buy a lot
less bread and a lot less milk and a lot fewer eggs.
But then the teak items out of the inflation index.
So it looks like there is no inflation.
Where's anybody who's trying to spend their dollars knows that things are
getting harder and harder and harder,
right?
These are the people running our money.
So bitcoin offers an alternative approach,
which says let's trust math.
Let's trust that the system runs based on a rule,
a simple mathematical role.
And everybody agrees that that is the rule by which money is created and no one
can monkey with it.
And,
and that's the beauty of it because if you know the rules,
it reduces the uncertainty,
it reduces the risk.
And when you have a simple system where people can interact with each other and
exchange money based on simple mathematic rules,
that system's going to do quite well because people no longer trust their
governments even here.
And it's much worse everywhere else.
Do you think that these issues that we have with the financial system and the
law enforcement system are sort of magnified by the solution of Bitcoin,
that this being the internet of money that really we need an internet of law
enforcement.
We need an internet of,
of,
of uh,
regulations.
We need what we all agree on.
We don't need what's been stuffed down our throat.
We need what we agree on by consensus based on the information that's currently
available,
which is what we would get if we didn't have some sort of a centralized group
that's in charge of deciding what's legal and not legal,
how things are enforced,
how things are done,
how,
how laws are,
are,
are created.
Let's talk about smart law and smart contracts cause this is a perfect
opportunity.
Bitcoin,
the underlying invention,
the blockchain asset ledger as it's called,
basically allows people to agree on who owns Watson to resolve differences
through this computation.
But the basic thing that means is that you can start doing smart contracts.
That means that you can put contracts into the system and then they either get
executed because the conditions are met or they do not based on mathematics.
So you could say,
for example,
I'm going to have,
instead of having a deed to my car,
the trench does with the TM fee,
I'm going to have a digital deed that's on the bitcoin network and when someone
pays me the money to buy that car,
that transaction is married to the deed transferring to them.
And the verification happens by the bitcoin network,
which I trust based on distributed consensus.
No one at the center,
no one monkeying with the rules.
So now you can start doing contracts and using the same basic mathematics to
fully resolve contracts.
You could have,
for example,
a parent setting up a number of transactions in the blockchain and the bitcoin
network is that send money to their kids in two decades when they're going to be
18 or 20 or 21 right?
So like a trust fund or a will and you could write that off as a contract and
then executed on the bitcoin network and the no one can stop it.
No one can reverse it.
No one can invalidate it.
That's pretty powerful stuff.
It allows people to have contracts between them,
between each other that are adjudicated,
if you like,
by the bitcoin network based on the mathematical rules.
And how would these things be enforced if they had to be in a court of law,
would that ever be an option?
Would they ever be considered legally binding?
Well simple.
The simple matter is that the transaction goes through or the transaction does
not go through the transaction as either valid because you presented the right
keys or it is not valid.
And once the transaction has gone through,
it's gone through.
I mean that's the simple way the network works.
So you know,
adjudication is something that you then have to deal with after the fact.
Like if a,
if a,
if a parent put a transaction in the bitcoin network that gave,
uh,
you know,
money to their kid as part of a will is that can't be contested.
When that kid presents the key,
that transaction goes through.
Don,
the network has agreed that that money has transferred,
it's transferred.
So it doesn't need a judge's written consent or it doesn't need
no,
it's mathematical rules instead without,
you know the,
the,
the benefit of this is that instead of relying on the ambiguity of language,
which is the basis of most law for many things,
you will have to,
but for some simple things like doing an escrow for a house or you know,
buying a car or transferring property or doing a trust or a will,
you could simply a convert those legal contracts into bitcoin transactions that
then get executed under a certain set of rules and suddenly you've got a form of
smart law,
self executing law that happens based on the bitcoin network's ability to agree
on what's true.
It's fascinating to think that this could be one step in an ultimate revamping
of our society and the revamping of our society based on the Internet and that
if bitcoin or and things like Bitcoin,
these peer used groups,
these groups of,
you know,
many people agreeing on a standard and a subscribing to a system,
if that can happen with this,
they can start happening with a lot of things could start happening with
education.
It can start happening with,
you know,
w w with even with law enforcement,
the idea of community law enforcement or,
or figuring out some way to a fun private law enforcement or private contractors
based on a situation like this.
So for,
for the biggest part of human history,
a lot of the most difficult problems like communicating at distances or agreeing
with lots of different people simply didn't scale.
And because you couldn't scale solutions to those,
we built hierarchal institutions to solve them.
Representative democracy,
we built councils and committees to solve decision making.
We built banks and central banks,
uh,
in order to solve issuance of currency and other things like that.
And we built hierarchal media organizations because we needed a single voice to
tell us what to think.
And then gradually we're seeing the solutions that are decentralized that solve
the problem without a hierarchal organization and that scale.
So the Internet was the first decentralized communications that scales to the
whole planet.
And so suddenly all of the hierarchal solutions for communication are no longer
necessary.
They solve a problem that doesn't exist.
The problem of it being difficult to transmit information across a continent or
across the globe.
Once our problem goes away,
the institution's built to solve it.
New Systems,
large entertainment and marketing organizations to,
you know,
create single output products.
All of those are no longer necessary.
And the choice blossoms.
Bitcoin is simply the same concept of decentralization but applied to money.
And one of the interesting things is the bitcoin at its core works on the fact
that you can decentralize voting and do voting at scale.
And the voting that's happening right now is the voting to agree on who has the
bitcoin.
But you could do voting for other things like
you know,
stocks,
bonds,
global lotteries,
national elections and things like that.
When you say
voting is to see who has the bitcoins.
So when,
when essentially the,
uh,
the mining process,
the verifies each block of transaction and secure set is like a giant votes in
election that happens every 10 minutes.
And by looking at the transactions,
you can tell who has the bitcoin.
If the entire network has said,
Andrea sent Joe a bitcoin and that's been verified by the network,
then everyone trusts Joe has a bitcoin and will be willing to accept that
bitcoin and payment for something.
Right?
So essentially the,
you have this every 10 minutes you have this consensus where the entire network
agrees on all of the transactions that have happened,
who has waltz,
what's going on on the system,
the ability to add,
have massive scale.
Have everyone agree on what the truth is?
That is the core invention behind bitcoin does that makes currency possible,
but it also makes other things possible,
including elections.
So you can do some pretty incredible things because what you've done is you've
decentralized decision making,
the Internet decentralized communications.
Bitcoin is decentralizing money,
but at its core is an invention that decentralizes decisionmaking yeah,
no.
What are the concerns as far as bitcoin getting shut down and what repercussions
or what,
what kind of blow back,
if any,
have you guys received the people that are,
uh,
in charge of,
you know,
spreading of this bitcoin
evangelists as it were?
I mean,
is,
is there any repercussions or any blow back or is there any,
nope,
nothing so far.
No.
I mean,
you know,
there's,
there's a little misunderstanding that happen every now and then and,
uh,
you know,
um,
people at first who don't understand the technology sometimes,
sit down and have conversations to understand it better.
But,
you know,
the,
the point is that at the moment,
bitcoin is legal to use and it's not just legal to use in the u s but it's legal
to use in pretty much every country,
um,
for individuals.
Certainly,
I think,
I don't think any country has bandit or has even attempted to ban it.
Um,
bitcoin is money as a piece of content that you can send on the Internet.
So if you,
even if you wanted to ban it,
who would be relatively difficult to do that without shutting down the Internet?
So that's one thing to put out there.
But the point is a,
nobody's trying to ban bitcoin.
Nobody's trying to shut us down.
I think especially in the u s and especially among senior lawmakers like the
Senate who had hearings,
uh,
recently about Bitcoin,
the prevailing attitude is,
look,
this is generating growth is generating jobs.
It's a huge innovation.
And,
um,
we see that it's being used at a very broad manner can change a lot of things.
You know,
maybe we should take a wait and see approach.
Uh,
and the price went up quite dramatically after they said that.
But the general attitude is most,
most politicians are far more interested in the possibility that this might
generate growth and also jobs and as a result,
votes and campaign finance money than they are about,
you know,
beating this down because it's going to affect different interests.
So there's still open to it.
And I think we've got a tremendous opportunity to educate people about all of
the incredible things we can do and also highlight the fact that this bitcoin
economy just in the last year has generated thousands of jobs in an environment
where we have economic stagnation.
We've got this bloom of innovation and technology,
uh,
much like the first burst of the Internet and you know,
that's a tremendous thing.
You don't want to squash that just because of a misunderstanding.
Do you think that there's a lack of blow back because the people in the powers
of be just having considered bitcoin to be a threat yet because we'll be talking
about like politicians not acting to try to the sound set to service.
They're the people that get him in the office a little.
The little the lobbyists or special interest groups that would have you like
that's just because they haven't been contacted by those people to try to do
something about bitcoin.
I think even the banks are ambivalent on this because while it may be disruptive
to some of their banking practices,
it is also one of the most interesting and innovative things to happen in
finance in the last hundred years.
And so I think a lot of banks are smart enough to say,
look,
we were good at technology.
Um,
we know money,
we've got branches,
we've got customers,
we've got marketing,
we've got brands,
we know how to do security.
We could really make a good deal with this bit coin thing and use it and make
some really interesting financial things.
So there's this mixed bag,
just like,
you know,
and I'll bring the same example.
When entertainment companies were first face with the possibility of MP3,
yes.
Some people were like,
oh my God,
this is going to destroy everything.
Music will die.
Right.
Which is the same they've said with every previous technology,
you're were right though.
Uh,
but,
but no,
they weren't because,
right.
But the,
the point is that since then,
the number of genres and number of artists,
the number of the amount of music has exploded.
Um,
people get a broader range of music than ever before.
And mp3s have created so much good in the entertainment industry,
so much more than damage.
Right?
And I think even in banking environments,
they recognize that with bitcoin there's this mixed bag,
which is that the good far outweighs the bad.
And even in a business that's going to get disrupted as banking will be just
like entertainment and telephone companies were disrupted by the Internet.
Um,
those that are smart can take advantage and they can build something good with
this and they're going to lose some power and leverage,
but they can make some good money out of this.
So I don't think any was out to get bitcoin right now.
Right.
I think people are,
are commonly evaluating it's,
and,
and thinking about what opportunities it can bring.
And I think that's the best approach.
Would you pull up,
uh,
about the taxes?
Because I guess there's this whole thing going on that people,
uh,
need to claim the,
the,
the stuff that the purchases or the money that they get from bitcoin on your
taxes,
but the IRS hasn't said how to do it yet.
Well,
I,
I mean,
I've discussed this with my accountant and they gave me a pretty
straightforward,
a formula.
If I earn income on Bitcoin,
I'm mark how many dollars it was at the time and I pay income taxes on that.
Just like anything else,
I've invested in some bitcoin.
If I hold it for less than six months,
I'll declare a short term capital gains more and more than a here I'll longterm
capital gains and pay the difference.
I mean,
that's basically how I would work with euros.
That's how I'm going to work with a bitcoin.
The key word you're saying how you're going to,
that's what's interesting about this is you actually haven't started doing that
yet because you've only been starting to get paid fully in bitcoin over the last
few months.
So this is fairly experimental even for you,
you're basically at the cutting edge of this,
right.
So I mean there are people who have already filed
Texas,
uh,
a few times and they've used the same approach.
Um,
I'm going to be filing income taxes in Bitcoin for the first time for 2013 but I
mean,
I'm discussing it with accountants and they think it's pretty straight forward
when I think the IRS will give us guidance before April.
And the reason I think they will is because the IRS is interested in or in
making revenue and what better way to make revenue from bitcoin than to simply
explain exactly how people should pay their taxes on it so we can,
things are going to get really weird if it takes off.
Yeah.
They're already weird and had already took off you think.
Yeah,
yeah,
absolutely.
I mean,
that's
of,
but I don't know anybody who's using it all the time.
I mean,
you might say if you're,
you know,
you're on involved in these online groups,
but the actual percentage of people that are using big coin and regular basis,
what is it,
one half of one half of 1% I mean is maybe
there are,
there's probably,
um,
you know,
several million.
Is it over 10 cents less than 10 in this country?
No,
worldwide.
But most of it's in this country.
There's a,
there's a million people in this country that are using bitcoin on a regular
basis.
Well,
that,
I don't know,
uh,
and it's,
and it's not easy to find out,
but what I do know is for it to be taking off is what I'm saying.
So what I'm thinking about is,
in terms of taking off,
this has been around for five years.
It's been a very stable and secure network that has preserved or increased in
value.
At the same time,
people have gradually improve the technology.
Now we've got this whole raft to startups that are doing innovation and
delivering better and better products around it.
More and more merchants are doing it and most importantly,
it's gone global.
It's now being used in dozens of countries around the world and the network is
large and getting larger every day.
So all of those conditions reminds me exactly of what the Internet was in 1992.
Again,
most people didn't hear about it until 94 95 and at that point you had people go
on the morning show and say,
you know,
is internet the email or what's this at sign?
And then we're having that conversation.
But it had already been growing quite rapidly.
I think that's where we are with bitcoin.
My mom is not going to do,
you know,
bitcoin on her own,
uh,
for another six or seven years.
Uh,
most people won't hear much about it for the next two years are going to hear
about it occasionally.
But in the meantime it's been building momentum and getting better.
And,
uh,
I think it's already arrived.
Certainly the invention behind it,
which has also spawned many other currencies.
Um,
you can't uninvent invent that invention.
So in whatever form.
And if it's not this bit coin currency,
which I think is already pretty damn strong.
Um,
you know,
that same invention can be repeated and improved.
Just like you know,
the Internet's the first early versions were really,
really clunky and gradually and improved and keep in mind currency is just the
first application.
So if you were on the internet and you only knew email,
you couldn't even imagine what the web would be like,
let alone social media or mp3s or digital music and video.
Internet still is a,
bitcoin is still like that.
We've got the bitcoin currency,
which is just like email and it's the basic application.
Now companies are building the other applications and it's getting really
exciting.
So I think we've got a bit to go until we're mainstream,
but I think it's already
catching on now in other countries it's the,
the government has been not so sweet about the use of bitcoin.
And there's an article that came out just a few hours ago from Russia,
the Russian central bank.
So the bitcoin users could face jail time.
They did.
Yeah,
it's up there.
It's actually was in Time magazine a this is off Lariya Novo Ski.
Alright,
lovely.
I'll just
as you know that other countries have done the same thing,
including China.
And I mean,
what if you use bitcoin and then,
you know,
two years from now they say it's illegal.
I mean,
are these,
well this is crazy.
This was released right before we started the podcast.
A couple of hours before we started this podcast,
they released the story.
So it's a fairly breaking news.
So I haven't seen the story.
What I can say,
first of all,
if it's saying that it's the same in China,
they're wrong.
So that makes me wonder what else they're wrong about.
But in China,
they banned central banks and other banking institutions from holding bitcoin on
their asset ledger.
They didn't ban people from trading.
In fact,
bitcoin is like 60% or more of the trading happens in China.
They didn't ban people from using it.
It's perfectly legal to use it there as well.
Um,
I think you might be,
it might be an exaggerated headlines,
but even if it isn't,
um,
you know,
if Russia bans bitcoin,
I think that probably ends up hurting Russia more than bitcoin.
Yeah.
China's limited bitcoin use for fruit citizens.
Apparently it's on a few different,
yeah.
China also limits a Internet to use for its citizens.
So that doesn't devalue the Internet.
I mean,
that's the,
that's the point about this.
And keep in mind,
there's also a matter of due process of law and there's also a matter of
different legal structures.
So for example,
in India,
the first reaction of the of the regulator is,
was,
well,
if it's not specifically licensed and permitted,
it's not legal.
That's their,
their legal system is attitude is we say it's legal,
it's legal.
If we haven't said anything about it,
then it's legal for,
right.
You need the license.
So it's the inverse of US law.
Um,
but,
uh,
you know,
certainly,
uh,
here in the U s I'm not,
I'm certainly not worried about it being pants,
hair,
because there is a lot of legal precedent for private currencies in this
country.
And there's constitutional protections and there's companies that can defend
themselves against that.
We,
you have a lot of people that listen to this podcast from other countries.
It's one of the reasons why I wanted to bring that up,
the Russia story,
but,
uh,
to point out that this is not a universally accepted things as far as the
governments and the ambivalence of American banks that they've shown an American
politicians.
This is,
it may not be the case in other countries.
Was this Bank of Russia issues warning on digital currencies?
Well,
you know,
Russia is incredibly suppressive place.
Uh,
we know that,
uh,
you know,
we know what's going on with them and gay people.
I mean,
it's,
it's a,
a really,
uh,
it's appalling,
very strange,
backwards country in,
in terms of a lot of the things that they think in a lot of the ways that they
behave as a nation.
And,
you know,
it's basically also run by one gangster.
It's a,
it's not a country of laws,
that's for sure.
Well,
I mean,
without a doubt,
Putin,
whether he's a great leader and not his,
uh,
his gangster,
you know,
he's just a super awesome when at it he's running the country.
You used to be the president stepped down,
put a puppet government and probably his and then became the president again.
I mean the whole thing is magical
and then rode around on a horse bare chested splendour.
Yeah.
That was pretty crazy and weird.
Oh,
he does a lot of weird things.
Him and Obama were,
uh,
they were both conflicted.
They were in some area and they were conflicted as far as like,
when they could use the gym,
take it.
They weren't allowed to use the gym together for some fucking reason.
Like as if Putin and Obama can't work out in the gym together.
Like,
do you know how fucking crazy that is?
dude,
I'll be on a stairmaster.
You hit the weights.
Is that cool?
No,
they can't be in the room together.
Like they're afraid that Putin might beat him over the head with a fucking club
or something.
But so while Obama was in the gym working out,
Putin jumped in the fucking lake outside the gym.
So in,
in clear view of Obama and his,
uh,
you know,
it's fucking elastic bands and he's doing his little aerobics stretches with
Putin swimming.
That's hilarious.
In a fucking lake.
Freezing,
freezing cold lake,
like a man,
like a bare chest at savage and an old spice commercial,
a Russian old spice master.
Unbelievable.
They're just pissed off about Alaska still.
Did you ever hear that old story that,
about how the,
they sold Alaska to us for,
I think it was like $12 million and then we bought it from them like an or
whatever,
1,817 hundreds and then we found so much gold in Alaska that,
that they would have,
you know,
tripled the amount that we paid for Alaska.
Even just on gold.
Forget the oil and everything else will ask is amazing.
They fucked up.
It's way better than Russia dummies.
They could have had a vacation spot and we'll,
anchorage is the shit man.
I was one of my favorite places I've ever visited.
It's amazing.
And the view that when you drive into the mountains,
oh my God,
it's just magical up there.
It's incredible.
Yeah,
I dunno.
Russia is a weird spot,
man.
You know,
Russia has had a long,
hard history,
has been a lot of horrible things that have happened to the Russian people,
both,
you know,
World War Two and before that there were,
they were occupied by the Mongols for 200 years.
I mean,
it's just a rough country and when it comes to their laws,
lemon,
they've got some really fucking shady laws and real weird attitudes on things
too,
man.
You know,
they have a habit of shipping people that don't agree with them off to Siberia
like that.
Um,
that one really wealthy oligarch fellow,
it was one of the most richest men in Russia,
but crosswords,
Putin,
Putin just sent that motherfucker to jail,
kept him in jail for 10 years and then finally released him,
have massive public outcry.
It's,
this guy was,
you know,
they trumped up charges against him.
Just locked them up in a cage for a decade.
Yeah.
Well,
here's the,
here's the other perspective on this switches in places like the u s if the,
if the government banned some things,
they go through a very long arduous process.
They go through courts,
they have to prove their case.
They can just willingly do it and it takes a long process.
And generally the people kind of agree with it.
Now in a lot of places in the world when something is banned by the government
that people go,
hmm,
maybe I should look into that.
So you know,
the fact that it's banned in Russia,
it doesn't necessarily mean the bitcoin disappears.
It simply means that bitcoin is more of an underground in that place.
And people have a lot less respect for laws that are arbitrary and capricious.
So in countries where you have week rule of law and you have rule of people
correspondingly,
the people don't pay much attention to those.
Uh,
you know,
a lot of things are illegal in Russia,
including s you know,
buying and selling dollars on the black market.
And you can do it on every corner in Moscow.
Yeah.
Isn't essentially illegal to be gay.
I mean,
what are the,
what are the laws on gay people?
They're incredibly restrictive.
Right?
Okay.
Yeah,
I have,
I don't know what the,
I don't,
it's not illegal to be gay,
but I think it's more,
um,
uh,
there are still sodomy laws and there are still,
um,
bans on public displays and things like that.
It's,
it's really,
or even symbols.
They arrested someone on the Sochi parade route with,
for holding a rainbow flag.
It was disgusting.
That's all
Marius the gays have taken over the rainbow.
I love that.
We rainbows,
we were a kid.
It's like fucking leprechauns pot of gold,
you know,
beautiful sunshine after the rain and now it's gay.
I'd the fuck did they do that?
You can get arrested for having a fucking rainbow shirt on.
I would.
I'm just a fan of rainbows.
What if this rainbow shirt and you got a Leprechaun at the end of it?
What did they say then?
If you have a rainbow shirt on the Leprechaun and a pot of gold,
I'm sure you get that.
To argue that in court about three months after you were arrested after spending
three months in a dungeon.
So yeah.
Well you have butt sex while you were in there,
so it might be great.
Well that's the old Lenny Bruce joke.
You know,
there was like one of the classic Lenny Bruce Jokes.
I don't understand why they would make the laws against homosexuality dig.
They take a guy who's gay and they arrest him and they put him in jail with a
bunch of men and when I have sex with them.
Yep.
It was Lenny Bruce,
Lenny Bruce.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
That was a classic.
That was one that people uh,
stolen.
They didn't even realize they stole it.
Yeah.
Because a lot of people sort of recognize that.
It's like when I was,
uh,
an open mic night comedian,
I've lived in Boston and Boston is of course south of New Hampshire and New
Hampshire had a license plate that said live free or die.
And of course,
the,
the old classic story about license plates is that they were made by prisoners.
So like 10 guys came up with that joke independently.
The live free or die.
Well,
the problem with that is,
you know,
they're made by prisoners.
That's one of those things.
Yeah.
Bitcoin,
what,
where did we go?
We went off track,
went into the woods.
Is there any kind of insurance or it company that's going to back up Bitcoin,
like an insurance company kind of like,
you know,
when a bank gets robbed,
US protected,
uh,
Ashley,
um,
as in many areas of kind of emerging markets.
One of the first to move in as Lloyd's of London,
which have historically been involved in,
in types of insurance that other companies won't necessarily offer first and
introduce the new market.
So there was an organization in the UK that will take,
uh,
where you can store bitcoin and then have it in short by Lloyd's of London for a
specific fee and they'll protect it from theft.
But here's the interesting thing.
Uh,
that's a,
that's a fairly limited approach to it.
But what you can do with,
with Bitcoin is you can take insurance contracts and the guarantees of insurance
companies and embed them into the transaction system.
So now you could have,
for example,
let's say when you go and buy something on Ebay and you do a paypal transaction
and they give you the ability to do escrow.
So if the product never arrives at your doorstep,
you can get your money back.
Right now when you do that,
you have to use paypal escrow.
You don't really have a choice.
And when you do that with visa,
you have to use visa escrow.
Well,
on Bitcoin you can pick an escrow provider and have them add their own key and
to the transaction and now they're going to be your escrow and you chose them.
Um,
so you can pick from a market of escrow companies and they can do it without
actually holding your money simply by putting an extra key in the transaction
and neither authorizing it or not.
I see.
So it opens up all of these possibilities for new forms of insurance,
new forms of escrow,
new forms of financial protections that couldn't be done with traditional money.
The edge,
there was news just out that a Jamaican bobsled team,
this was from bitcoin was it,
but it was a dodge coin or whatever it's called,
raise $30,000 for this year's a Olympics.
Just the other day.
Yeah,
and I mean,
here's the other is story that's not told very often,
which is the charity aspect.
In study after study,
after study looking both the charitable organizations and user profiles,
um,
and questionnaires,
bitcoin users have said repeatedly that the number one thing they do with their
bitcoin is donate or give them away.
Um,
charity is very active on the bitcoin blocks blockchain on the bitcoin network.
just recently,
bitcoiners raised a ton of money for the hurricane and the Philippines.
Um,
there's a number of charts we'll organizations helping the homeless in Florida.
there's other organizations doing the same in San Francisco,
all based around bitcoin.
So there's this incredible charitable giving spirit and it's on,
we're seeing that replicates with other coins to,
um,
one of the other interesting ones is the wikileaks recently announced that the
vast majority of their,
uh,
donations now come in cryptocurrencies.
Bitcoin,
unlike coin,
this is fascinating because on certain payment networks,
you can't donate to,
to Wiki leaks,
right?
You can't donate to wikileaks was pay pal.
You can't donate to wikileaks with visa.
They ban you from doing that.
And that's how they've cut off the funding of that organization.
Yet at the same time on some of those payment networks,
you could donate to the Ku Klux Klan.
Now,
that doesn't represent my principals and I have a big problem with that.
Well,
with bitcoins you can because you simply can't donate to whoever you want.
You can just send Bitcoin to any address.
And as a result,
um,
you know,
wikileaks has seen rise in the donations
they receive,
uh,
through bitcoin.
But a lot of other organizations too,
it's,
there's a lot of charitable giving.
There's a lot of nonprofit organizations using bit coin.
This is a fascinating time.
I mean,
how many other Bitcoin,
like alternatives are available.
And do you feel that those are competition for big,
for Bitcoin or they just as valid as bitcoin?
Is there room for a bunch of cryptocurrencies?
What's the,
what's the attitude about that?
That's a great question because we,
uh,
generally speaking,
the term for alternative currencies is altcoins.
Uh,
some of them are alternative,
some of them are,
uh,
more competitive with bitcoin.
All of them are based on the same invention.
So what this shows is that the underlying invention of how to do computational
agreement on the network that invention has spawned all of these other
currencies.
Uh,
some of them are very innovative,
some of them are just fads and memes and some of them are pump and dump schemes.
So there's a whole range.
One of the interesting things that this has created is that in the past money
was trusted and had value because not many people could create it.
And so we trust governments to create money.
And money has value because only governments can create money now because anyone
can create money.
How you give it value depends on other things,
which is actually a good lesson because government money doesn't really have
that much value in a lot of places either.
It's just an illusion that somehow that makes it valuable.
In the case of Bitcoin,
what makes bitcoin valuable is the enormous amounts of investment.
Uh,
both in terms of resources,
in terms of the computing equipment that people have bought in terms of the
invested companies that are in it and the people who work in it.
Um,
other coins have slightly different variations of the same theme.
and some of them are based on memes,
Internet memes.
But here's,
I see a future where a five year old at school could use a web browser to build
a coin in an afternoon and launch it among their friends.
So will there be more coins?
Yes,
tens of thousands of them.
And we'll,
those coins have value.
Probably not,
no more than baseball cards or Pokemon or a Tamagotchi.
But within an environment and with young people,
you're going to have,
you're going to have people who create them for trading purposes and as memes
and,
and fats.
And so they'll have a certain kind of value,
just not monetary value.
So you have to evaluate which coins have monetary value based on what's running
behind them.
You know,
the bitcoin economy has an actual economy behind it has merchants,
it has retail transactions,
it has a startup,
companies that are investing in developing things with it.
Some of these other coins have some of those things.
Some of them have none of those things.
But is there a risk of bitcoin being like the myspace of cryptocurrencies when
you get off to
his big headstart and you're way ahead of the game,
but there's holes in your game and right?
Facebook comes in and steals all your people.
So one thing to realize is that money is a lot more sticky than a social site.
Um,
and when people invest their skills and expertise and companies into a certain
cryptocurrency,
that carries a lot of weight.
So bitcoin has already achieved a very high level of network effect,
which means that the more people are on it,
the more people that attracts,
the more people that are on it,
the more people that attracts.
But at the same time,
because it's building a capital base that makes it,
that makes it very difficult to unseat bitcoin.
Um,
I think what we'll end up seeing is,
uh,
one or two major currencies.
Bitcoin is probably going to be the biggest,
um,
and then two or three or four or five secondary currencies that do some kind of
niche thing that's useful for some group,
um,
that bitcoin can't do a won't do because it sounds like for example,
a bitcoin has reverse inflation deflation because there's a fixed supply.
So over time the value is gradually going to increase,
right?
Um,
other people have created coins where if you don't spend them,
you lose a bit,
which is like inflation.
So bitcoin is not going to be able to copy that and take,
take that feature and say,
Hey,
that looks good,
let's do it too.
But for a lot of other things,
when an,
when an alternative coin invents something new,
bitcoin can simply pick it up and run with it to a big coin hasn't stopped
moving.
It was invented in 2008 and five years of innovation have gone into it and the
level of innovation is accelerating.
So I think there's a lot of room for a lot of coins in this space and not all of
them are going to have value,
but some of them will have value.
So are there any that stand down?
I know Doge Coin Dog,
he coin is one that keeps getting brought up to me to,
to talk to you about on the Internet.
What about Kanye West's coin?
You know,
Kanye West has a coin,
so I think there are a few coins that have interesting characteristics.
Um,
you know,
they implement new features,
they do things slightly better or slightly different in some ways than bitcoin.
So what,
like what,
what do they do better?
Um,
well for example,
um,
one example is a light coin.
And what light coin does is it has a different way of,
of having the agreement on the network,
which is,
which requires more memory on your computer in less CPU.
So that makes it,
um,
more level at the same time.
Uh,
it does transactions that are on a different pace.
So instead of every 10 minutes,
it does,
um,
you know,
fewer minutes for per block.
I think it's two and a half,
and then you have a larger number of total coin.
So it's a few tweaks.
The idea is if bitcoin is gold,
light coin is silver.
Um,
but that's the general competitive environments.
Now,
beyond that Doge coin is in fact or dog coin or Doggy Coin,
whenever,
I'm not quite sure how it's pronounced is,
is an enhancement on the original,
um,
idea of light coin.
So it took that and then twisted it a bit.
And then you've got this whole list of other coins that,
um,
some of them are interesting.
One discovers prime numbers,
which are useful in mathematics and the other one uses a different peer to peer
system.
Um,
another one is more programmable.
One of the new coins that's come out now,
ethereum allows each transaction to be a full code for programming language.
Um,
you know,
all of these may have interesting characteristics and then,
Kanye West coin,
you know,
whatever,
and hey man,
dumped,
dismiss it.
No,
I mean it's great.
It comes to goal first.
First of all,
they got sued I think,
or they got cease and desists because they had nothing to do with him.
Um,
but one of the interesting things is that we don't know if one of these catches
on,
who knows why not a lot of things in life started as a joke and then became huge
things that became embedded in the culture.
So what,
let me ask you this.
What about these massive fluctuations in value,
like day to day,
right?
In intense fluctuations?
Yes.
Very disconcerting to people that are looking for a stable investment.
When you see what are the,
I mean,
several hundred percent,
right?
What is the worst day or the best day as far as the variation?
So I think the best day was a was maybe two and a half years ago,
which was a minus minus 40 minus 50% in a day.
That was a really big crash and it took it to from above 32 below a dollar.
Um,
and then there was another crash around a hundred and then there was another one
around to 66 and then there was another one around the thousand.
And so we're now kind of in a relatively stable band,
uh,
between 800 900,
somewhere there.
Okay.
Explain.
But here's the point over time is these little hiccups get narrower and
narrower.
And here's why they occur.
If you look at the bitcoin,
the total market capitalization,
if you take all of the bitcoins that exist times the value that they have on the
market today,
it's about a $10 billion market,
right?
$10 billion market might sound like a lot,
you know,
certainly if it was a tech stock,
it would be a nice size tech stock.
But as a currency is puny,
you know,
there are hundreds of countries that have bigger monetary base for that
currency.
And this is an international currency.
It's small.
So what happens is this is a shallow pool of,
of uh,
liquidity.
And when you have a shallow pool of liquidity like this with a few markets that
are not very efficient,
the end result is that every time someone sneezes,
all of the liquidity sloshes around and you get these fluctuations,
but as it gets bigger in size,
the waves get smaller,
right?
So it's not as volatile.
And if you look at it,
uh,
if you plotted on a graph and you plot the volatility,
you'll see that every year it's getting less and less and less and less and less
volatile.
Now,
if at some point it became large,
you know,
the reason currencies like the u s dollar on it are not very volatile,
is because if you think of a $14 trillion economy is like a titanic,
it takes,
you know,
three miles to turn 10 degrees,
right?
So they're much more stable because they have weight behind them and inertia.
And even if you want to change it,
you tweak something now and it changes in six months because it takes time to
filter through the economy.
Meanwhile,
think of Bitcoin is like a little Zodiac boat,
makes the titanic bouncing up and down the waves,
very nimble,
both volatile over time as it gets bigger than the waves get smaller by
comparison.
Okay,
what is the cause of these fluctuations to a financial dunce like myself?
What,
what causes?
Like how can it be worth x amount and then half that in the case.
So let me start by answering the implicit question of how does it get its value?
Who sets the price?
Okay,
so it's a free market.
Uh,
and so if you go and try to buy bitcoin online at the moment and you say,
I'm going to pay 800 for it,
and someone says yes,
and then during the day the vast volume of people are buying and selling for
around a hundred $800.
Great.
That's the price of bitcoin.
It's whatever people are paying to buy and sell bitcoin.
And so every time the order changes,
you know,
if suddenly you can't find anyone to buy your bitcoin at 800,
you're going to discount it a bit and discount until you find someone who's
going to buy it.
And then that's the new price.
So it will go down a bit.
But if you are finding people easily to buy your bitcoin,
then you increase the price of it.
So it goes up a bit.
Just like the stock market.
Who sets the price of IBM?
No one,
it's whatever the last deal was on IBM stock.
So,
uh,
how's that not make it vulnerable for the same pump and dump issues that you're
experiencing with all these other cryptocurrencies?
Well,
it,
it's,
it does make it vulnerable,
but the point is there's still a fixed amount of bitcoin.
So right now that small fixed amount of bitcoin with,
you know,
very big changes of media news piece comes out and it's like Chinese people are
buying bitcoin woo.
And it goes,
you know,
really high.
Everybody gets really excited.
This is,
it is breaking through.
Then the next week,
Central Bank of China won't let banks hold bitcoin down.
We go,
you know,
every piece of good news pushes the price up.
Suddenly every piece of bad news knocks it down suddenly,
but it seems like really manipulative financial experts would be able to move it
left and right to their whim in order to profit off of it.
Yeah,
on this probably a bit of that going on,
but I can tell you that there is a lot more of that going on in every other
market.
So that's the interesting thing here.
We now know that Libor,
the interest rates in the Lenten than bank system has been fixed for years and
that's the basis for most interest rates.
We know that the gold markets fixed,
we know that the stock markets,
they're doing front running on high frequency transactions,
those are fixed.
Every single market out there is currently rigged and so the people who are
playing within these markets with like fiber optic connections to this main data
center,
you know,
and they're three feet closer than the other server and can get that transaction
in four nanosecond sooner.
Our front running transactions are benefiting,
are profiting from that distance and these markets are rigged.
You know,
you go in with you a little brokerage accounts and you trade some IBM and you
think you're playing the game,
right?
You're the dunce in the room cause you don't know who the dunce and the room is.
What you're talking about with automated transfers like that where you're
dealing with Nano sock,
high frequency trading as it's called their algorithmic trading.
Unbelievably fascinating stuff.
Yes.
I mean literally they have racks trying to get closer to the rack where the
transactions are happening until data centers had to say,
no matter where you are in the room,
you're getting 300 feet of fiber and if it's coiled at the bottom of your rack
or if it's stretched out,
since you're still going to have to go soon so that everybody gets the same
deal.
But right now,
for example,
uh,
all of the banks are playing this game.
How can fast can you do a transaction?
So what I'm saying is yes,
there is manipulation in the bitcoin market,
but the manipulation is on the stock,
on the exchange rates,
is that that happens on a day to day basis,
but it's not on the supply of money.
Whereas in the real economy,
the stock market,
the New York stock has changed.
Not only is the market rigged,
and not only is the market been manipulated,
but the currency itself is rigged and being manipulated.
The Fed is printing money and handing it to the banks.
So the lesser of two evils,
it's definitely the lesser of the two evils.
And also the larger it gets,
the harder it is for outsiders to manipulated,
right?
Because they don't control the levers of power of the currency.
There are no leavers,
and that's the beauty of it.
So you create a system that doesn't have leavers to control the currency.
So all they can control is the price and manipulated.
But that's a dangerous game to play long term because if the market turns
against you,
you lose a lot of money too.
So it's currently worth how much is a bitcoin worth in American dollars?
Um,
so one place to look up is bitcoin average.com and that shows you the average
across dozens of exchanges all around the world.
At the moment it's a 700,
hang on one bitcoin is 784 US dollars on average at the moment.
And that's fairly stable cause you were talking about it at 800 before.
So it's pretty close for the last month it's been in that band.
Um,
we have seen some wild swings,
but it seems to be stabilized around that level now,
which by the way is three times the level it had stabilized before the big
bounce and how much bitcoin is actually available out there in the world.
So I'd have to look that up.
I would say about 11 million or so have been created so far.
And there's a constant creation of these every 10 minutes,
25 and this constant creation will eventually not just level off,
but one day stop.
Yes.
Now what happens then?
Well,
the thing is it,
it's,
it starts operating more like a precious metal,
which is that,
you know,
once supply of a precious metal gets restricted,
it increases in value.
But the one difference is that a precious metal,
you can only shave so thin,
you can't cut it into smaller units and it's difficult to transport and all of
that.
Where's Bitcoin?
You can divide it into 100 million sub units.
So basically instead of the money in your pocket losing value over time because
the central government is diluting it,
it's getting concentrated because more people want to use it,
then there's not enough around.
So it gains value in your pocket and that's a deflationary currency.
Uh,
it creates some interesting savings opportunities.
Where do you see this going?
How,
how,
where do you,
what do you see like the future and a hundred years from now,
what do you,
what do you think bitcoin's place in the world is going to be?
I think I can make certain predictions for sure.
And I can make other predictions with absolute 90% margin,
which means I'm pulling it out of my ass.
So let me tell you one I can make for sure.
Cryptocurrencies will be part of our financial future period.
Doesn't matter what form they take.
This invention has been invented.
It will change finance,
it will change banking.
Uh,
and it might not be bitcoin.
I think it will,
but it might not be bitcoin,
but it will still be a cryptocurrency.
The idea of having a mathematical currency based on a distributed peer to peer
network happened.
The invention happens.
You can't stop people from coming up with variations on it.
You can't easily shut it down if you shot down 100,
others are going to pop up in its place.
Now at the same time,
I think bitcoin has a very good chance of being the one that was good enough.
The grew fast enough and gained enough traction that it will actually have,
uh,
as a store of value value for a very long time.
Now,
didn't someone sell a house and Canada through Bitcoin?
We've seen transactions as big as $150 million by the way.
Guess what the fee was?
What?
Zero whoa.
Hundred and 50 million transferred in seconds for zero fee.
Whoa.
Who?
Who got $150 million in Bitcoin?
Justin Bieber.
That crazy.
Fuck who's who did that?
Were they drunk?
We have no idea.
Oh,
they must have been drunk as well.
No,
no.
I mean,
you see,
look at the text messages.
You mean when you were drunk and then look at your bitcoin folder.
I did what you think you would know if somebody spent that much money using
bitcoin because they would,
you know,
as a bitcoin user would probably scream,
I just spend on one point $5 million.
That's why it's so weird for me to think that like the the guy that created it,
no one knows is what he looks like.
Some guys,
he spent one point $5 million but no one knows who this guy.
It just seems so weirdly.
Here's the thing,
you don't know what's happening in the banking system today.
People are sending billions of dollars around,
but for bitcoin users,
they're all,
it's almost like buying a cell phone in your advertising.
Like this is the best cell phone ever.
I love it.
You know that your cell phone sucks cause they are almost the most vocal about
using bit coin that you would think somebody going to spend 1.5 would,
would immediately go to online.
What do you mean?
Hold on,
I'll tell the world I have all this money.
That's a dangerous thing to say.
Why would you,
why would you think that that's what they would do and if they didn't do that
they wouldn't,
it wouldn't be real.
No I didn't say it's not real.
It just says it seems so suspicious that you know that there's so many.
See that my biggest problem cause I've been,
people have been trying to get me to a bitcoin for the longest time is things
like this where it's,
it just seems there's so much mystery to it like that.
Especially if you follow the conspiracies of the,
the guy that created it.
And if,
and you know you hear reports like somebody just spent,
well you know all these millions of dollars using bit coin.
Yes.
I already said,
he said someone bought one point $5 million,
transferred to $5 million transaction.
There was a transaction from one address to another address,
$450 million in a single transaction who can keep in mind minute 150 million.
Yes.
And these happen every second.
Not Not that big,
but transactions happen all the time.
And so as you,
if you were watching the stream and transaction,
you're like,
you know,
$10 a thousand dollars $500 $10,000 150 million.
And you're like,
what?
Well,
and you can see that transaction because it's on the public ledger.
And it did happen and it has been firefight and the transaction went through and
they paid zero fee.
So this hundred and $50 million transaction was between two people.
It was between two addresses.
So it might've been person moving in from one of their own accounts to one of
their own accounts or,
or given it someone else.
But it's still 150 million American dollars worth of.
It was about (406) 140-5000 bitcoin and bitcoin is worth $800 each.
Yeah.
So at the time it was almost a thousand.
So yeah,
it's about 150 million.
Wow.
Which in the big scheme of things,
by the way,
in the global monetary system is peanuts,
but it's not user though.
If it's either an individual you or if it's an a,
is it a corporation?
The corporation might be the government.
Yep.
When we seize the Silk Road,
the government,
meaning we,
uh,
Hu
government,
the government keeps,
keep kept that right there.
They're actually,
um,
I don't think they want to keep it for too long and I'm not sure they,
they are allowed by law to keep it for too long.
So what they've announced they're going to do is they're going to sell it.
They're going to sell Silk Road.
No,
they're going to sell the bitcoins.
They seized
and they're going to sell them on the,
on some kind of market or auction,
which is,
which is great because it's going to create some discount treating.
That's funny because bitcoin was a key player in that whole silk road scandal.
And for folks who don't know what Silk Road was,
it was a website that allowed you to buy a lot of illegal things online and some
of it was purchased through bitcoin and those things were,
is illegal as drugs or as guns or there was a lot of different things,
right?
Yeah.
Well it's the,
it's was mostly drugs and the just today,
53 minutes ago or whatever,
I don't know the guy
that,
those two people got arrested for that from the,
the,
they had a company that was a,
a laundering money using bitcoins,
allegedly,
allegedly.
Definitely someone who sold bitcoin to users who bought drugs.
Right,
exactly.
Money Laundering for drug.
Let's be clear,
the allocation,
I read the indictment and on the plane,
and I'm not a lawyer,
but what it,
what it said is that allegedly,
uh,
these people sold bitcoin to someone who then resold it on the Silk Road to
other users,
some of whom he used it to buy drugs.
So how could somebody be responsible for,
that's up.
That's like,
that's a three hop allegation.
And in my mind,
if that's the standard,
then at least half of Wall Street should be in cuffs.
Right now the thing it's allegedly,
so let's keep that in there.
I mean,
yeah,
many we've used many allegedly is,
it's very important.
Well this is a,
there's a lot of exaggerated,
exaggerated claims and statements in prosecution indictments.
When you're a career prosecutor and you write up the indictments and decide to
take it to the grand jury,
you're not going to just write the littlest thing you do.
You're going to make it look like,
Eh,
you know,
every person who arrest is the worst person in the world and has massive crimes
going on,
which means that reading fats and seeing how much of a weak case it is,
you know,
allegedly sold to someone who allegedly sold to users who allegedly both drugs.
Um,
I dunno,
it seems insane.
It's almost like your employee,
uh,
buys drugs with money that you paid him so you are in trouble for him buying
drugs.
I'm not a lawyer.
I'm not going to figure out what sort of connection,
the same direct sort of connection and let's see them try and prove it.
I mean that's the best,
the justice system.
You have to,
you have to prove it.
Yeah.
But it's so scary that someone's freedom is on the line for something as
ambiguous as that.
Especially when you're dealing with someone's selling bitcoin to someone who
used then use that bitcoin to buy drugs once it's out of your hands.
Scary as he got a 24 year olds sitting in jail for this.
And you've got the 55 year old CEO of HSBC who didn't even resign after being
fined hundreds of millions of dollars for laundering billions.
Yeah.
What the fuck?
Government don't make us use the internet to run everything that's gonna happen,
right?
Yeah.
I mean this is actually probably owned by the government and there you're going
to use it and voting in the future and like you said,
it's probably going to be,
it doesn't matter if it's owned by the government.
Look,
listen,
the government,
the government invented the,
the basic protocols behind the internets and then engineers and geeks took it
and turned it into a global network.
And even if the governments had invented the math behind bitcoin,
we know how it works.
It's math and we're using it to do things that the government doesn't
necessarily control that well.
So if they did invent it,
that was a bad idea.
Often some people,
someone says it was the internet,
the underlying technology,
there's nothing mysterious about it.
Can read the source code.
You can see how it works,
you can understand how it works and you're not trusting anyone specific.
You're just trusting that you understand how it works and it's math.
I mean,
that's the beauty of it and that's why it people are adopting it so easily is
because there's no one behind the curtain.
Yeah.
It's,
it's also,
it's sexy.
You know,
it's the new kid on the block.
It's the new exciting thing.
It's the,
the,
as you said,
the Internet of money.
Yeah.
And people want to be the first adopters.
They want to get on it first.
Okay.
That flux happening in this economy.
I mean really,
let's think about it.
What else is happening in this economy now other than the military under,
other than I'm more derivatives piled on the Huppah more derivatives by the
banks.
Pretty much everything else is at a standstill.
Set Marijuana.
The money from marijuana.
Yeah.
Well that's the one thing in this economy that's exploded in the places where
it's been introduced and allowed to,
to uh,
operate in the free market.
And ironically,
those,
the,
the situation there was that they weren't letting those people who are selling
the marijuana put their money in banks.
The government has since amended that and said that they're going to now start
allowing these people who run these medical marijuana stores to,
uh,
put their money in banks,
which is a huge victory.
And I think,
you know,
ultimately it's unconscionable.
Do anything else because you're,
you're allowing a,
an environment where crime,
violent crime is most likely going to take place because you are making people
targets.
If you're not allowing them to bank,
you're,
you're making sure they have massive amounts of cash on them on a regular basis
and they're going to get targeted.
It's just a matter of time.
You're,
you're creating,
you're going to create victims of a violent crime.
So I'm glad they decided to not do that.
But that's a perfect example of the kind of fuckery that's involved in our
government that you could have these people that did pass a law allowing
something to be legal.
And yet still those people are kept from in prohibited from putting that money
in banks.
It's nuts.
It's madness.
I mean,
the broader scheme of this is understanding that there's ways to deal this
through law,
including the People's propositions in these states.
And then there's a lot of these extra legal,
uh,
you know,
shenanigans that happen where suddenly someone gets audited for a dozen years in
a row,
right?
Yeah.
And Yeah,
J J Edgar Hoover had people audited every year of their life,
um,
because he didn't like them.
And some of those practices,
Keno continue to this day.
Now I prove least like to see the rules followed.
I mean that's the whole point of this country is,
and it's a rule of law equally apply to all.
At least if we know what the rules are,
you can follow them or choose not to and then face the consequences.
But if you don't even know what the rules are because people may come up as they
go along,
that's not a good place to live.
Yeah.
If a a business,
a private business acted the way the IRS did as far as like handing out audits
to people that were political opponents,
handing out audits to people that were personal,
opponents of people that in power,
if a private company acted out that way,
they would be guilty of all sorts of fucking violations.
It probably be somebody in jail.
I mean it would be a really big issue if you found out,
but they've been auditing people just to fuck with him for the longest time.
It's,
it's pretty gross and scary thing.
Well,
the good news is there now to auditing bitcoiners and so far we have a nice
relationship,
uh,
with the IRS and they're looking for ways to help us pay our taxes.
And I'm looking forward to that time.
I'm looking forward to filing my taxes,
uh,
and paying them this year.
I'm fascinated.
I mean,
I pay them every year paying,
paying Texas specifically for the bitcoin earnings I've had this year.
I'm fascinated,
I'm fascinated to see that this yuck Amo Nakamoto guys.
How do you say his name?
Satoshi Nakamoto.
So Toshi Yakamoto,
have you met this cat?
No one's been solution that Comodo I think got real.
That's what I'm saying.
Well,
I mean there's,
there was a possibility no one's mad at him.
There was a possibility that,
well,
here's what we know.
We know what he wrote and based on what he wrote,
we know his name by changing it to numbers and doing it backwards and googling
stuff.
And it was Savannah.
If you type in his name backwards into Google,
it leads you to this whole real long a discussion on some board about bitcoins.
And I'm like stealing them.
And stuff like that.
It's a really weird,
okay,
I stopped.
Just continue.
Sorry about him.
No,
no,
no.
The,
the,
the thing about Satoshi Nakamoto is we,
he's written a scientific paper,
right?
And before that paper,
and after that paper,
he participated in the community for two and a half years having conversations
about how to do this.
So what we know is he's a scientist.
He's a scientist,
heavily involved in cartography and economics and in digital currencies,
which is a space that's been thriving for 20 years now.
And he,
she,
they found a way to solve a specific,
whoa,
Whoa,
whoa.
He,
she,
they,
so does she Nakamoto might not be a person.
Satoshi Nakamoto might be a woman.
Satoshi Nakamoto might be a group of two or three people collaborating under a
pseudonym to create a scientific solution.
It doesn't matter.
They invented science.
Oh,
for sure.
It doesn't matter,
but aren't you fascinating?
Oh,
I'm totally fascinated.
But here's the lesson we've learned.
Prometheus's stole fire from the Gods and gave it to the people and they tied
him to a fucking rock and had an eagle eat his liver every day.
So Tosha Nakamoto gave money to the people and he disappeared because he's smart
enough or she's smart enough not to get tied to a rock.
That's the bottom line.
I don't look into it because I think only bad things can come out of,
uh,
outing Nakamoto.
I see what you're saying.
They get smeared immediately.
Right.
And there's nothing good that will come out of it because at the end of the day,
since they control nothing,
and since what they invented is a mathematical solution,
it doesn't matter.
So you believe that potentially
this group of people or individual person,
whatever it was,
whichever scenario,
whichever sacks that they,
they
thought about it in advance and Oh,
they said they spent several years working on the,
I mean there active and not just the,
the code.
I'm talking about the repercussions of their actions and they decided to be
anonymous in their delivery of this.
Well,
I think throughout the 90s a lot of the people involved in digital currency
environment because some of them were working in oppressive,
highly oppressive environments.
And you know,
people may be working from Burma or from China or from who knows where.
And so it's not a good thing to be doing these with your own name attached.
So they made a lot of people in this space where involved anonymously to protect
their own safety.
I was at working in digital currencies,
basically doing science work in cryptography ends,
mathematics and distributed systems.
That's a very sexy part of the story.
You can't leave that out anymore when you tell the story.
You got to tell people that nobody knows if Satoshi Nakamoto is even real.
That's kind of cool.
Yeah,
it is kind of cool.
But,
uh,
you know,
we do know some things about Satoshi,
for example,
he puts two spaces after every period,
or she or she or they were,
or is that guy?
That's the Toshi,
Toshi.
A lot of people have tried to gas and there's a lot of uh,
a lot of digital currency,
uh,
scientists and cartographers,
well known cryptographers who participated in the creation of many of the
aspects of bitcoin and people are fingered them and said,
you know,
maybe that's the toll.
She may be,
that's the Toshi,
maybe they're also Toshi.
I am Sitoshi so this is sort of almost like a jack the ripper sort of
investigation only.
He didn't kill anyone.
He gave science to the people.
Well,
I mean in terms of,
there's so many different theories of who you ever watched a documentary on it
solve Jack The ripper is murder,
you know,
they always find out that it's a totally different gods.
It's like a great story.
I mean,
you know,
this person invented a completely new science people or people and,
and then disappeared for their own safety and yeah,
that's pretty cool.
Yeah,
it is fast and it's going to be ripe for conspiracy theories of all kinds to
jump out of that.
And you know,
I tried to focus primarily on the technology because I,
it stands alone.
That's the key.
It doesn't need any of this.
There is a culture,
there's a history,
there's all of that.
Then it's fascinating,
but the technology just works and it's simple math and people can read it,
understand how it works,
and then use it.
And that's the beauty of it because it doesn't depend on anyone.
You don't have to trust the Toshi.
You don't have to trust the bank and you don't have to trust that someone's not
going to mess it up because you can see how it works.
That's such a subject as ripe for conspiracy theorists.
Boy,
they're going to jump all over that one.
Then you got a big foot.
They're going to chem trail the fuck out of that one.
Okay,
well,
yeah,
it's,
it's a,
it's already happening.
The tower seven,
this shit out.
How can we make a connection with bitcoin entire seven?
There has to be something.
It's all fun.
Tower seven.
Hell,
the original computer that created Bitcoin,
it wasn't done at 2008 it was done in 2001 the NSA,
the CIA,
and the DEA.
I've met that guy,
Alex Jones.
Oh,
was that complex?
Jones?
I was just guessing.
I've met several guys like that.
Yeah,
well there's a lot of those guys.
Boy,
there's some fucking
ferocious conspiracy theorists out there.
Um,
I'm,
I'm fascinated by these things.
I'm fascinating by these new avenues that our culture starts going down and
these incredible avenues and branches of possibility off of these new new paths.
It's just a really amazing,
amazing time in so many ways.
And this highlights just this constant repeating subject that comes up with me
and my friends is that W it's,
the Internet has changed everything,
everything.
And we've pretended that it's only been a little bit,
oh,
so you get email now.
What's the big deal?
It's,
it's monstrous.
Yeah.
It's changed.
It's changed my life.
A 100% change the way I think 100% changed my connection with just random human
beings.
I,
I interact with thousands of random human beings online on a daily basis.
And 99.9999% of those interactions are positive.
Yes,
exactly.
That's the most beautiful aspect about it.
Like
bitcoin is just an expression of that.
It's a child of the Internet.
You know,
when people say,
you know,
the intranet now is so cooperative and restrictive that you can't do anything.
Well I can tell you you can because bitcoin came right out of that and works on
that perfectly today.
So you know,
the bit bitcoin is one more thing that happens because of the Internet and now
it's turning around.
And here's the interesting thing.
It allows you to do very small transactions,
micro nano transactions.
So for example,
if you want to monetize your podcast and you accepted bitcoin and people sent
you a 10th of a penny or a penny or a dollar and you added up over hundreds of
thousands of users because it doesn't cost much to send because it's an easy
transaction.
People will make transactions smaller and smaller and smaller.
So suddenly bitcoin can fund all of the independent content providers and all of
the independent infrastructure providers on the intranet and transformed the
Internet again from the inside out.
Wow.
Like imagine all of these media companies that have gotten so horribly disrupted
because there's basically two media models.
If you make content on the Internet,
you either sell advertising.
So you're stuffing junk into the eyeballs of your customers or your ears.
And the bigger the company,
the more junk that comes out of it,
right?
Or you're selling your customer if the product is free,
your the product,
right?
Right.
Your personal information is what generates the value.
So if you're on a social media site that's free,
you're the product.
And so they're selling your information in order to make money.
So it's either advertising or selling your information.
Well now there's this third way,
which is you can do transactions small enough to have value when accumulated in
large numbers.
The you could independently and directly funds content providers and
infrastructure on the Internet and break the hold of these,
you know,
um,
systems of concentration that advertising and social media have become privacy,
selling privacy and,
and selling advertising,
which require concentration.
They require enormous concentration.
What do you think if we set up a dedicated Joe Rogan experience?
Bitcoin server right here where we do not server,
but computer could have advocated to just crunching just out of respect.
Yeah.
I just have one running here in the background all the time.
Yeah,
we joke.
Can we go to jail for that?
Is that possible?
No,
of course not.
In fact yet,
you know,
at the end of the show,
uh,
I'd like to help set you up with a wallet on your,
on your smart phone and I'll send you some bitcoin.
Sure,
sure.
Um,
the other question I wanted to ask you about,
we,
we spoke about earlier was net neutrality.
Now,
um,
that that's a huge issue for anyone who loves the way the Internet works and the
way the internet does not judge and the Internet is freely available to anyone
who poe ports into it at virtually whatever,
you know,
you pay for your connection,
your,
you're going to,
you know,
whatever your download speed is.
But there's no,
there's no regulation as far as like it being easier for Walmart to get online
or they have more of a percentage of the pipe or what are we concerned about net
neutrality being somehow or another compromise by nefarious sources?
Well,
I mean that's your travels.
He suffered a massive setback in the courts just a couple of weeks ago with a
decision that allowed to Verizon communications,
so not be subject to the FCC rule,
imposing net neutrality,
and that sent shockwaves through the industry because the average down what?
What was the,
the Internet lost.
What?
What was the case?
The case was the FCC made a rule that said that carriers must support net
neutrality and for ice and suit and had it overturned as unconstitutional or
outside the mandate to the FCC to be more accurate.
What did Verizon specifically want?
Well,
we don't know that they say they want to make the internet better,
but they just got the rule that says that they have to treat all traffic equally
taken out.
And most people don't realize that the reason the internet allows things like
Netflix to happen is because they didn't have to ask anyone's permission.
Now imagine if when Netflix started it had to ask Comcast to run as traffic and
pay for premium.
Well,
they wouldn't do that because it's a competitor.
So of course they'd crowd the out of the market with exorbitant fees.
Net neutrality means that everybody has a fair shake to be heard and it's up to
the end user to decide who they want to listen to.
All of the traffic will reach you if you wanted as the listener or as a viewer.
Now,
Ken,
they somehow or another limit where the traffic goes to like what we're seeing
in other countries where they have restrictive internet laws.
Is that a potential,
I think for product to this case,
I think the biggest threat right now it comes to companies like Netflix or
things like I'm streaming radio and audio systems,
a Spotify,
Pandora,
etc. Whereby a service providers who have their own TV streams or their own
music streams that are competing are going to make their experience great.
And Netflix experience somewhat suckier,
so they'll limit the bandwidth of Netflix applications.
They'll choke them.
Right?
Right now.
I mean they already do in some cases,
but how they do that?
Well,
I mean they all kinds of shenanigans,
but I mean the bay,
the basic deal is that this FCC rule was trying to establish a legal framework
on the,
which they'd be obliged to give equal access to all contents as long as the
viewer chose,
that's what they want to see.
Or they wanted to connect to all of the Internet.
They would connect to that with the same bandwidth that they've bought.
A,
you buy bandwidth and you use it for whatever you want and you don't get better
bandwidth if you use their shows.
The Netflix,
well,
once they tried to put that rule in place,
you know,
um,
the lawsuit started and now we have a very bad decision that could really,
really hamper innovation.
A lot of the things that we see today on the Internet would not have happened if
net neutrality weren't observed and the Verizon,
for many people who don't realize this,
Verizon offers home Internet connection as well as four g and,
and TV most importantly,
right.
And pay per view and video on demand,
which means that they're directly competing against other content providers.
Verizon now has a fiber optic system that's,
you know,
incredibly fast and connects to you direct download movies and television shows.
There's a lot going on right now as far as um,
uh,
as far as internet related content,
things like Netflix and things like,
I mean Hulu and Hulu plus and there's these places are now starting to create
their own programming as well.
Right.
Getting really fascinating cause they're not just competing with Verizon now.
They're competing with NBC and CBS and what have you.
And if you like that net neutrality is why it happens and therefore we should be
defending that you trial.
So what people should do is probably boycott companies that don't support net
neutrality.
Sure.
I'm a huge supporter of the eff electronic frontier foundation that's been
fighting for privacy and liberty.
And then you travel to on the Internet since the early nineties,
and they've won several substantial cases both against organizations like the
NSA,
but also against a service providers that tried to abuse their position to
prioritize traffic.
And they've promoted the idea of an open,
independent,
transparent and fair Internet for all,
uh,
with equal access for everyone.
I mean,
that's the thing that's made the Internet magic and they've
been@theforefrontofdoingthattoeff.org I'm a huge supporter.
That's interesting.
Well,
we'll look into that and maybe we'll fucking put an eff sticker on our website
or something like that.
And you can put it on your webcam too.
They're the same ones who sell those little things.
Yeah,
well those guys are on the ball.
that's,
that's something to really be concerned with.
It really is the idea that they could limit your experience,
whether it's Netflix or whatever.
Downloadable charter does it to Jamie.
I,
they won't let them go to pirate bay anymore.
And I've heard that before.
Allegedly,
allegedly,
allegedly he doesn't go to pirate bay.
Fuck,
well,
I need to download a legal lego league,
legal music,
legal like nine inch nails.
So if you're in an area where they have a lockdown on,
on Internet providers,
you know,
where some people like can only get Verizon,
they're in an area that only gets rise and like 18 t doesn't reach their time
Warner's and reach there.
That sucks.
That's,
that's so disturbing.
And it's so contrary to the,
the trends that we would like to see as far as,
here's one good idea.
One could thought that comes out of this.
A lot of the problem right now is that you pay for both of your infrastructure
and your content in a single payment.
Your Isp,
well with bitcoin you could pay the recipients of the content provider directly
in tiny,
tiny,
tiny payments.
So you really are the bitcoin genius,
your bitcoin Jesus.
Because you,
um,
he is because he's buying bitcoin as a solution for everything.
Well,
I mean,
it's powerful stuff fixed that and bitcoin can fix the Internet.
Bitcoin can fix Verizon.
It's almost an I'm not,
it's just,
you know,
it's almost like evangelists stick like it almost like a,
like pyramids.
Like when you go to a pyramid type thing where they're sounding like,
no you're not you.
Is there anything you don't like about it?
Like what's the number one thing that you're like,
I hope something changes with this.
Is there anything,
yeah,
sure.
I mean it's got a,
it's got some scalability issues that are being solved.
It's a,
it's software so we have to be very careful with the upgrades.
Um,
but you know,
I mean compared to the existing form of money we have,
I honestly think it's better money and it's,
and it's a great technology.
I've spent 20 years doing security and distributed systems.
That's my area of expertise as a professional.
So what I love about this is that I can see the elegance of the technology and I
understand its implications.
The last time I felt like this was 1992 and it was because I saw the internet
and I saw the elegance of its and I was out telling as many people as I could,
you know,
this is really going to change things in ways you don't even expect.
And I can't even explain to you yet because it's going to unfold in ways no one
anticipates.
Because what it does is it democratizes information.
So yes,
I'm excited about something that democratizes money,
but it's because I understand the underlying technology.
Uh,
you know,
I don't profit from talking about this.
Uh,
I'm able to build a career on it.
Sure.
And I love doing it,
but really at the,
at the heart of it,
I'm a geek.
I love the technology and that passion just comes through.
It's obvious.
It's obvious that you love it.
You light up and you,
you when the word bitcoin comes out of your mouth,
it comes out just covered in love juice.
You love it.
It's obvious and it's interesting and it's,
it's,
um,
you're in a very unique position because you're really at the edge of it and
you're,
you're sort of at the front of this ever increasing in mass ship and a,
you're watching a game momentum.
It's got to be pretty exciting.
It's exciting.
It's,
it was also terrifying
for quite a while.
I mean,
I've been in this full time for almost two years and I can tell you that that
was a not a very profitable,
a job for living before that.
Um,
I've been an independent freelancer.
I've been starting businesses.
I'm an entrepreneur,
so I was an independent freelancer and linking them.
What,
what is your,
your,
your background,
your education and background?
I'm a computer scientist with a specialization in distributed systems.
Uh,
I've been working in security for just over 18 years in information security
systems.
So I worked as a consultant.
I worked as an advisor.
I worked as a chief information officer for companies.
I built research companies.
I built,
uh,
companies that built,
Internet systems and I followed the Internet.
I'm not one of the pioneers of the Internet.
I was the 16 year old kid looking over their shoulder as they were doing these
things,
you know,
so I was buried in it when I was young and you know,
so I've,
uh,
I've worked as a,
as an independent professional in this space for many years.
And then two years ago I first discovered bitcoin.
Then it hit me again a second time.
I read this little sheet of paper and I decided this is the job I'm going to do
and right now if there is no job,
so I'm not gonna make any money at it,
but I'm going to do this job until it actually becomes a job.
And I did that for two years and I almost went bankrupt because there wasn't a
job there at the beginning.
And now it's a job and it's very exciting.
So this is a conscious decision on your,
your part back when it wasn't even profitable?
Oh yeah,
absolutely.
Massive chance and stepped out on the edge of the dock.
Yes.
I invested in several companies.
I drained my retirement accounts,
I drained my savings,
paying my bills until I could generate income doing this.
Wow.
And I,
I've,
I mean this is not prudent investment.
This is not prudent behavior financially.
But as a,
as a technologist,
as a person who's worked in distributed systems and,
and security and computer systems,
I could see that this was an exciting technology and I want to build a career in
it.
So what I've been doing is swapping money for skills and experience and the
opportunity to be on the ground floor.
I was too young when the Internet started to to be influential in that space and
I see this opportunity as a second opportunity to do that.
Now.
How did you know that Bitcoin was the solution?
What made you so confident that you invested as exorbitant amount of time in,
in,
in bitcoin and you know back two years ago that the future could not have looked
nearly as bright as it looks now?
So the key,
the key here was that I was in distributed systems and security and then the
first time I thought I heard about it,
I thought nerd money and then the s like everybody does,
right?
That's where Brian is,
that possible can't possibly work.
Then I went back and I read this a Toshi paper and I grasped the science and it
was confusing that I read it again and I really grasped the science and then
suddenly it hit me.
Oh my God,
this isn't a currency.
It's a consensus network.
This is the grail of distributed systems.
Of the last 15 years,
you can do so much more than currency.
And once that light bulb went off,
all I could see was the possibilities.
Oh well now that we have this technology,
we can do this and this and this and the currency will do these things for us.
And you know,
all of these possibilities unfolded in my head.
And it was,
it was a really dizzy experience,
but I understood the fundamental building blocks looked so much like the early
Internet and I knew what structures like that do.
They create a network effect.
They create this attractive force where it gets more useful the more people who
use it.
Now,
work effect was coined first by Bob mad calf in 1984 he said the value of the
network increases exponentially with the addition of each node.
Because when you join a network,
you don't just getting that value,
but by increasing the size of the network to make it more valuable for everyone
else because they have one more person to connect to.
Right.
And if you keep doing that,
it achieves a scale where it starts multiplying.
That's how the Internet grew and when you have this magic combination of money
for the people that can be sent directly between people,
the forms,
a network,
those three things came together.
In my head I'm like,
this is,
this is big and nobody knows it yet.
And when you see something that big and nobody knows it yet,
you want to tell everyone and you want to dedicate a large part of your time to
doing this because it's incredibly exciting.
Now,
how did you initially jump in?
I mean,
how do you jump in in the infant stages of,
of Bitcoin,
what it,
what's the steps that you took to become a part of this?
Well,
I spent months and months and months reading everything that I could,
the scientific papers and discussions that Satoshi Nakamoto had with the other
developers as he developed it.
I started reading the code,
I started writing code,
I started building businesses around it.
I started talking to people.
I started meeting up with other bitcoin enthusiasts and then as soon as I could,
I started buying bitcoin and you know,
and basically have been doing that since.
And what does your average day now consist of going on podcasts and telling
people how awesome bid coin is?
How often does that come up?
So I have a day job on the technical advisor and a number of bitcoin startups.
I am the chief security officer for blockchain Info,
which is the largest bitcoin web wallet,
uh,
in the space.
Um,
and I work everyday as a media,
uh,
you know,
as a media pundits,
a commentator on bitcoin.
I write code and then I comment about it and I do interviews all the time
because this is something I believe in strongly.
I don't get paid for my interviews.
I have other jobs that allow me to pay for international travel for a long time.
That was my savings account until,
uh,
until I was able to get other beans.
Buble you certainly hope to eventually profit off of this.
Oh,
actually now I'm making income on Bitcoin,
so,
so let's,
so things are stabilized.
Uh,
you know,
I'm not a bitcoin millionaire.
I'm may never be a bitcoin millionaire,
but I know what career I want to do for the next 15 years.
Wow.
So how did you know that bitcoin was going to be worthwhile and that so many
people are going to jump on the board?
A jump of board two years ago,
it seems like two years ago it was like,
I didn't know.
I mean what I knew is this is a very elegant technology.
The had some implications,
some geopolitical implications,
some cultural implications,
some technology implications.
And I liked all of those and I was very interested in pursuing it.
And at the time I hoped it was going to get baked and I figured,
you know,
if it didn't and uh,
and I didn't get anywhere with it,
I could do something else in a couple of years.
You've got to come on again in a year.
I'd love to,
yeah,
let's,
let's let this thing cook out there.
In the crazy world,
I mean what we say a year,
but the way things are moving,
three months you might be right.
It was getting crazy in terms of what happened in the last year alone.
It's been unbelievable.
I mean,
we had our first major bitcoin conference in April in San Jose,
and now there's like a hundred conferences going on this year.
Wow.
And there's $150 million transaction.
Right?
Exactly.
And the price was that,
you know what,
I was working on this,
the price was $15 I,
I,
if you asked me last year,
it did.
I think bitcoin would be at a thousand.
I said,
no,
y'all may be in a couple of years.
I was surprised too.
But you know,
it has a way of growing on you.
And when it does,
it grows as a network and people find it useful and they try it.
They understand how it works,
it's practical.
They grasped the usefulness of it,
and they start using it.
I wish I had you in here when Peter Schiff was in here.
I'd be like sick Andreas.
Tell him what's up.
Maybe he's right.
I don't know who's right or wrong.
No,
I don't generally debates on this because the simple truth is that none of us
know.
Right.
And the reason we don't know is because the tools we have to analyze currencies
don't apply because this is a completely different type of currency.
It's not a stock,
it's not a currency.
It's not an asset.
It's not a commodity.
It's a bit of everything.
Um,
so can I tell you what it's gonna do in two years?
Of course not.
I don't know.
Nobody knows.
What I do know is I understand the technology and what I see as something
elegant and practical.
So I'm interested in seeing where this experiment will go.
Because here's the thing,
if it doesn't work,
some people lose money.
If it does work.
We changed the world of money forever.
And that's a pretty big thing to say.
But cryptocurrencies I think are here to stay.
They offer an elegant solution to decentralized money.
And with a bit coin survives or not.
I want to see where this is going to go because it has the possibility of
changing a lot of people's lives.
Well,
it certainly does.
And I want to see them find that Nakamoto thing.
I want to see who it is.
Oh,
I hope they never find him.
Yeah,
cause you're,
you're,
it's like big foot for you searching for a searching for sugar,
man.
For me,
I want to find them.
It's probably gonna be something you already know to like the dude you got a
Dell guy or somebody.
It's unbelievably fascinating.
It's just unbelievably fascinating.
Especially listening to you describe it.
Um,
your,
your
passion for it makes it even more fascinating.
It's a,
it's really something that I'm going to keep my eyes on and try to follow.
So,
uh,
I appreciate you coming over here and I appreciate you,
giving us your knowledge and spending your time and,
and uh,
I guess I'll,
I'll set up,
I'll watch it on my phone now,
so,
yeah,
sure,
sure.
Absolutely.
And if we set up an android phone,
yes.
Right.
Okay.
So you can,
you can download the blockchain.
And I said before I,
I work for blockchain as the chief security officer.
I was a customer long before that,
but I think it's one of the better ones.
Okay.
So you download blockchain from your app store and a,
then you'll get an address.
And I can then send you some bitcoin and you'll have it in a few seconds
to put up a computer here.
A dedicated computer that runs can help you do that.
Coin computations wouldn't fuck with us in any way,
right?
With,
no,
not at all.
Mess with our band.
Dan,
what's your electricity?
Electricity.
I mean you can get a little one that's even a USB sticks.
They call it like a Klondike insulate a little as stick USB stick.
You plug it in and he just swapped some electricity and it generates a bitcoin.
You're not going to generate monster.
I'm not trying to get rich off.
Come off.
Maybe it's going to be printed to play with.
That's cool.
Bit Coin Street credit.
That's what I'm looking for.
Yeah,
exactly.
All right.
Listen man,
this was very enlightening.
Um,
uh,
I'm obviously going to have to read a lot of shit after this.
There's so much involved in this subject and so much involved in crypto
currencies.
It's a,
it's really,
really interesting stuff,
but I think it's bad ass man.
And I really respect a guy like you who takes a giant leap like that and,
and dives into something and something that you believe in and you get really
passionate about it.
It's what life is about to me.
It's about pursuing passions and I love the fact that you're really into it and
I really,
really appreciate you coming on here and enlightening us.
Thank you so much for having me.
And you know,
sometimes you,
you choose the things you want to do in life,
but some of the most interesting things in life,
once you find them,
you have no choice.
I had no choice.
I couldn't sleep at night if I wasn't doing this.
It's still a choice.
It was just such a,
it's such a big drop.
But yeah,
I mean I hope you see,
you know,
I'm not trying to sell anything.
I am genuinely passionate about this because I see an elegant solution.
Yes.
Well that is where,
you know,
the choices,
the choices and being that person who follows their passions,
that's inspirational to me.
It's one of the most inspirational things I encounter both online and in the
real world is watching people who are passionate about what they do
do.
Right.
You can recognize it in others.
Yes.
Yeah.
It's the only way to live your life
contagious for me.
Like it could be a guy who makes handmade knives,
you know,
and grinds the blades and sharpens the handles and,
puts everything together.
I have fascinating,
but I'm fascinated by anything that someone's incredibly passionate about.
And,
uh,
so this,
this bit coin thing now it's just now it's in there.
Now it's in my list of things I'm fascinated about.
Right.
Well,
thank you very much.
So people want to get in touch with you.
Uh,
they can,
uh,
contact you on Twitter.
Probably the easiest thing is Twitter.
Yeah,
that's the one I can handle the most.
But listen,
you're going to get swarmed.
Try not to pay attention to all those fucking psychos.
Okay.
It's a n t o n o p.
That's a n t o n o.
P on Twitter.
Um,
and,
uh,
entrance.
Is there anything else that you have a website,
a antonopoulos.com.
Um,
yeah,
sure.
That's why media sites and people can book me for engagements there,
but a really on Twitter is where I'm most active.
My name is pretty easy to Google and to thank you so much for having me.
I really,
yeah,
please is.
It was an honor.
Um,
I really think we had like a crazy internet pioneer in here.
This is good.
Some day we're going to look back on this and say,
man,
we have Andrea from,
I know we should a bought that coin and apple stock.
Let us know what the fuck is.
He told us not to.
We could have had a whole room full of computers.
Man,
we shouldn't listen to him.
Back then.
He didn't have enough faith.
Uh,
thanks a lot man.
Awesome.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Uh,
to everyone else.
Next big date I got coming up folks,
uh,
is um,
I am in Dallas,
Texas with Ari Shaffir and Duncan Trussell.
That's March 14th at the Verizon theater this weekend,
this Friday.
Um,
uh,
um,
it's sold out.
I mean New York,
but don't try to get tickets because if you do get tickets and just support and
scalpers,
so unless you find somebody online that's,
that can't go cause they're posts,
it got wet,
but whatever.
Do what you gotta do folks.
Um,
so that's the next big one.
Uh,
is uh,
Dallas,
Verizon theater.
March 14th.
Can't fucking wait.
That's the day before the huge UFC event at Dallas stadium,
which is apparently like 50,000 seats or something.
Bananas.
So that should be a lot of fun.
Um,
that's it.
All right,
you freaks.
We'll be back this week with uh,
many more podcasts to be scheduled and many more conversations to be had.
A much more fun and uh,
and much love.
Thanks to our sponsors.
Thank you to squarespace.com the greatest resource online for creating websites.
Go to squarespace.com and use the offer code Joe and the number one.
That's one word,
Joe and the number one and save 10% off your first purchase.
Squarespace is the first place you should stop if you're even thinking about
making a website.
Thank you.
Also to legal zoom.com go and do your legal stuff online at legal zoom without
going to a goddamn lawyers office.
Legal Zoom is not a law firm,
but they can connect you with a third party attorney if shit goes off the rails
and they can also provide you with self help services.
When you check out,
use the code word Rogan in the referral box and thank you also to onnit.com
that's o.
N,
n.
I.
T.
Use the Codeword Rogan and save 10% off any and all supplements.
All right,
you fox.
We love the shit out ya and we'll see you soon.
Big Kiss.